Happy New Year, you guys! That's right. It is the end of 2020. We're moving into 2021. It's very exciting. Get here, 2021! Get here! Come on!
新年快乐，大家！没错，2020年就要结束了，我们正在迈向2021年。这真的让人很激动。2021年快来吧！快来吧！来吧！
Come on now! Well, listen, we just wanted to pop on here and wish you guys a great, great New Year. But we're not the only ones. We are not the only ones. Mother folks want to wish you Happy New Year, too. Let's hear from them. Hello, Jenna and Angela. This is your friend, Steve Carell.
快来吧！听着，我们只是想冒个泡，祝大家新年快乐。但我们可不是唯一的。我们真的不是唯一的。还有其他人也想祝大家新年快乐。让我们听听他们的声音。嗨，珍娜和安吉拉。我是你们的朋友，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。
And I just wanted to say, I declare Happy New Year! Happy New Year, you guys, and Happy New Year to all of the listeners of The Office Ladies. Hey, everybody. It's me, Kate Flannery, Meredith from The Office. Hey, I'm here to wish you a very Happy New Year. Put some clothes on. Wishing you all a safe 2021. Just remember, a hangover won't last forever.
我只想说，我宣布新年快乐！新年快乐，各位，也祝《办公室女士》的所有听众新年快乐。嗨，大家好。我是我，凯特·弗兰纳里，《办公室》里的梅雷迪思。嘿，我来祝大家新年快乐。把衣服穿上。祝大家2021年平平安安。记住，宿醉不会永远持续下去。
It just feels like it does. This is Oscar, wishing The Office Ladies and all their wonderful listeners a Happy New Year. Hey, Office Lovers. This is Phyllis Smith, also better known as Phyllis Vance, Vance Refrigeration. I just wanted to wish you all a very happy and healthy New Year in 2021. And we'll put all these crazy days behind us and move forward into a beautiful, coming New Year.
只是感觉上会持续很久。我是奥斯卡，祝《办公室女士》和所有优秀的听众新年快乐。嘿，办公室的粉丝们。我是菲利斯·史密斯，也就是大家熟知的菲利斯·万斯，万斯冷冻公司。我只想祝大家2021年新年快乐，身体健康。我们会把这些疯狂的日子抛在脑后，迈向美好的新一年。
So, Happy New Year, you all. Hi, this is Leslie David Baker, wishing you and your family a merry Christmas, a joyous holiday season, and a happy, healthy, and prosperous New Year. Take care. Stay safe. Hey, Office Fans. It's Mindy Kaling, Friends of the Pod, The Office Ladies Pod, of course. And I just wanted to say Happy New Year, oh, oh, oh, that's my Santa impression.
所以，祝大家新年快乐。嗨，我是莱斯利·大卫·贝克，祝你和你的家人圣诞快乐，假期快乐，并祝新的一年健康、快乐、万事如意。保重，注意安全。嘿，办公室的粉丝们。我是敏迪·卡灵，播客的朋友，当然也是《办公室女士》播客的朋友。我只想说新年快乐，哦，哦，哦，那是我的圣诞老人模仿秀。
Was it good? I can't tell. Hey, everybody, it's Craig. Have a safe, wonderful, blessed New Year. This is BJ Novak, and I'd like to woof everyone a very Happy New Year. Woof.com. Hey, everybody. John Krasinski here, wishing you a fantastic New Year.
学得像吗？我看不出来。嘿，大家好，我是克雷格。祝大家过一个安全、美好、有福的新年。我是BJ·诺瓦克，我想对所有人“汪”一声，祝大家新年快乐。Woof.com。嘿，大家好。我是约翰·卡拉辛斯基，祝大家新年快乐。
Hello, Office Ladies. Hello, Office Ladies, Fans. It's me, Brian Baumgartner, here, wanting to wish you a ho, ho, ho. Happy New Year. Yes, let's work together in 2021 to make it 2020 awesome. Happy New Year from this grandstri- Paul Leverstein, gotta be more careful, kidding. I'm like, I don't know, Happy New Year. Greetings, this is Rainn Wilson.
哈喽，《办公室女士》。哈喽，《办公室女士》的粉丝们。我是布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳，想祝大家“霍，霍，霍”新年快乐。是的，让我们在2021年一起努力，让它变得像2020年一样棒。来自这位大叔— 保罗·莱韦斯坦，得小心点，开玩笑的。我说，我不知道，新年快乐。问候大家，我是雷恩·威尔逊。
I play the character of Dwight Schrute, and congratulations, it is your New Year's Day. That is all. Hey there, Office Fans and Office Ladies, listeners, Ed Helms here, and I just wanted to wish you all a very Happy Reddit, the New Year. It's Creed, wishing you Happy New Year, later gang. Oh my gosh. You guys, that has me tearing up. I just loved hearing everyone's voices so much, and it's just a special group of people,
我饰演德怀特·施鲁特这个角色，恭喜你们，今天是你们的新年。就这样。嘿，办公室的粉丝们和《办公室女士》的听众们，我是埃德·赫尔姆斯，我只是想祝大家红迪网新年快乐。我是克里德，祝大家新年快乐，回头见，各位。哦，天哪。天哪，这让我感动得都要哭了。我太喜欢听大家的声音了，他们是一群非常特别的人，
and they love the show, and they love its legacy, and they love you guys. All were so wonderful when Jen and I reached out, we sort of divided up a list, we started texting everyone, and everyone was like, absolutely no problem, and that was just so wonderful, and thank you guys so much. Thank you, the cast of the Office, for sending in those New Year's messages. I love it. I think you can just hear the love in their voices, the love of this thing that they got to be a part of.
他们热爱这部剧，热爱它的传奇，也热爱你们。当我们联系大家时，每个人都太棒了，我们把名单分了一下，开始给每个人发短信，每个人都说，完全没问题，这真的太棒了，非常感谢大家。谢谢你们，《办公室》的演员们发来这些新年祝福。我太喜欢了。我想你能从他们的声音中听到爱，对他们曾参与过的事物的爱。
We are on this text thread together, Angela, but I haven't heard a lot of people's voices in a while, and so when we would get those audio clips in, I just, every time, it was emotional. Yeah. Well, that was wonderful, and we love you guys, and we were thinking, what is a great way to ring in the New Year, and Jen and I are with our families, and we're in our sweat pants, no doubt about that. But there is an interview that we absolutely love, and who better to ring in the New Year
我们在一个群聊里，安吉拉，但我已经很久没听到很多人的声音了，所以当我们收到那些音频剪辑时，每一次我都觉得很感人。是的。好吧，这太棒了，我们爱你们，我们在想，有什么好方法来迎接新年呢，我和珍娜都和家人在一起，穿着运动裤，毫无疑问。但有一个采访是我们绝对最喜欢的，还有谁比
than with Creed Bratton? Yes, guys, you might remember, we had Creed in the studio with us back when that was allowed, and he stayed with us for the entire episode when we broke down Halloween, so we wanted to replay that for you now. It was a really special treat, we laughed, we cried, it was great, so guys, happy New Year, from the Office Ladies, from our team here at Ear Wolf, Cassie, Cody, Sam, Ainsley, we love you. We love you guys, hang out with Creed, and we're sending you all our love.
克里德·布拉顿更适合来迎接新年呢？是的，大家可能还记得，以前被允许的时候，我们把克里德请到了录音室里，当我们拆解万圣节那一集时，他在我们这里呆了整整一集，所以我们现在想把那段重播给你们。那真的是一次特别的款待，我们笑了，我们哭了，太棒了，所以伙计们，新年快乐，来自《办公室女士》，来自我们“长毛象”团队的卡西、科迪、萨姆、艾恩斯利，我们爱你们。我们爱你们，和克里德一起玩得开心，我们把所有的爱送给你们。
We'll see you in 2021. We'll see you next year. It's almost here. I'm Jenna Fisher, and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together, and we're best friends, and now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch Podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
我们2021年见。我们明年见。快到了。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们一起出演过《办公室》，我们是好朋友，现在我们专门为你制作了终极办公室重温播客。每周，我们会剖析《办公室》的一集，并带来只有亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。
We're The Office Ladies. I love it. Creed is here. Creed is here. Creed is here. Creed is in the house. Yeah. This is so amazing.
我们是《办公室女士》。我太喜欢了。克里德来了。克里德来了。克里德来了。克里德大驾光临。耶。这太棒了。
Creed's going to be with us for the whole episode, guys. Okay, Creed, you're our first in-house visitor, right? I mean, we've had people call in, but you're our first in-house guest. I'm the first one. I might have a bathroom break or something. It won't be for the whole thing, but I'll be in and out. We can provide you with a bathroom break. That'd be good.
克里德这一整集都会和我们在一起，伙计们。好的，克里德，你是我们的第一个内部访客，对吧？我的意思是，我们有过电话连线，但你是我们的第一个内部嘉宾。我是第一个。我可能得去上个厕所什么的。不会全程都在，但我会进进出出的。我们可以为你安排上厕所的时间。那挺好的。
I'm old. I'm old school. Well, I'm old, so that's part of it, you know. I need everybody to know that I've already teared up twice since Creed has been here. You've said two touching, well, first of all, just seeing you. Almost burst into tears, but then you've said like five amazing things that have touched my heart already. We get together with you, it's just back, we're back on the set, you know, and it's
我老了。我是老派的。嗯，我老了，所以这也是一部分，你知道的。我要让每个人都知道，自从克里德来到这里，我已经感动得哭了两次了。你说了两个感人的，首先，光是看到你。差点哭出来，但你随后又说了五件了不起的事情，已经触动了我的心。我们和你聚在一起，就像回到了片场，你知道的，一切都
all like, oh, I miss you girls. Creed lives down the street from me. I think everybody who knows me knows this. Don't give him my address, please. I won't. Creed's address is. His hidden key is, yes, we are neighbors and it's one of the joys of my life that we're neighbors.
就像，哦，我想念你们这些女孩。克里德就住在我的街区。我想认识我的人都知道这一点。请别把我的地址给他。我不会的。克里德的地址是。他藏备用钥匙的地方是，是的，我们是邻居，作为邻居是我生命中的乐事之一。
I love that you're right around the corner. I love that we have- We see each other walking. We see each other walking. We see each other hiking around the street. We do. Hey! Hey!
我喜欢你就在拐角处。我喜欢我们有——我们看到彼此散步。我们看到彼此散步。我们看到彼此在街上远足。我们确实如此。嘿！嘿！
Was it your daughter's dog? Your son's dog. My son's a little Yorkie, yeah. A little Yorkie, and I hear, hey, pumpkin! And I turn around and it's Creed. And we've also maybe had some adult beverage in red solo cups. We may have. We may have.
那是你女儿的狗吗？你儿子的狗。我儿子的小约克夏，对。一只小约克夏，我听到，嘿，小南瓜！我一转身，是克里德。而且我们可能还用红色塑料杯喝过一些含酒精的饮料。我们可能喝过。我们可能喝过。
And we like to do a little bit of what we call the sauce trail and walk around having a glass of wine. And watching documentaries. Oh, yeah. Creed loves anything where like animals go crazy, like planet earth. Yes, all that stuff. I just love it. All right.
我们喜欢做一点我们称之为“酱汁小径”的事情，一边拿着一杯酒散步。一边看纪录片。哦，是的。克里德喜欢任何动物发疯的东西，比如《地球脉动》。是的，所有那些。我就是喜欢。好吧。
Well, we are really excited to have you here. Wow. We are discussing the Halloween episode. Yes. Right. Right. Season two, episode five. This was written by Greg Daniels and directed by Paul Feig.
很高兴你能来到这里。哇。我们正在讨论万圣节这一集。是的。对吧。对吧。第二季，第五集。这一集由格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，保罗·费格执导。
And it is the first episode that Creed speaks. Well, I actually spoke in the diversity day. In diversity day, I had lines with Phyllis. Yes, I told her. And they paid me afterwards. Well, the first day, first day D, remember that girl we had, the first day D. Yeah. The first season.
这也是克里德开口说话的第一集。其实我在《多元文化日》里说过话。在《多元文化日》里，我和菲利斯有台词。是的，我告诉了她。他们后来付钱给我了。第一天，第一天的那个导演，还记得我们当时有那个导演吗，第一天的导演。对。第一季。
She thought I was part of the cast at the time. So she came in with her little hands and she said, now you and Phyllis just start talking. And Phyllis said, wait. I said, never mind. That's okay. Never mind. Phyllis was going to get out of you. Phyllis was going to get out of me.
她当时以为我是演员阵容的一部分。所以她迈着小碎步走过来对我说，现在你和菲利斯开始聊天吧。菲利斯说，等等。我说，没关系。没关系。菲利斯正打算套你的话。菲利斯正打算套我的话。
So I said, never mind. It's fine. And so we started, I started talking about, you know, sacrificing goats or something. Of course you did. You know, trying to tell her what was on her head. You're improv with sacrificing goats. Yes. Yes.
所以我说，没关系。挺好的。然后我们就开始，我开始谈论，你知道的，献祭山羊什么的。你当然会了。你知道的，试图告诉她她头上顶着什么。你即兴发挥了献祭山羊。对。对。
Fantastic. So you can hear me in the background. And they later, and they said, wait a minute. Creed's talking in the background. And I said, oh shoot. How did that happen? Yeah. How'd that happen, Creed?
太棒了。所以你能在背景音里听到我。后来，他们说，等一下。克里德在背景里说话呢。我说，哦糟了。怎么会这样？对。怎么会这样，克里德？
And they, they, they paid me on the side, but they didn't say, but we can't, I said, no, it's fine. It's fine. And then not off camera. Then also was the voice for the, the ride. Yes. For the mining ride. For the mining ride, you know.
然后，他们私下付了我钱，但他们没说，不过我们不能，我说，不，没关系。没关系。然后不仅不在镜头前。后来还成了那个游乐设施的声音。是的。矿山车的语音。为了矿山车的语音，你知道的。
You were so funny. I think they paid, they paid attention to that one. Yeah. You were so funny as the voice of the mining ride. And Isabelle was watching that episode with me and she said, mom, I know that voice. I know that voice. And I was like, wait, you're, oh my gosh. She was like, I think it's Creed.
你太搞笑了。我想他们注意到那个了。是的。作为矿山车的配音，你太搞笑了。伊莎贝尔和我一起看那一集的时候说，妈妈，我认得那个声音。我认得那个声音。我说，等等，你是，哦天哪。她说，我觉得是克里德。
She's like, I'm discerning to she. She is. I mean, I didn't catch it. And then I looked it up and I'm like, Isabelle, we do know that voice. It's Creed. Yeah. But anyway, this is the first time where I actually was, was had some, had some serious lines.
她说，我听得出来就是他。她确实。我的意思是，我没听出来。后来我查了一下，我说，伊莎贝尔，我们确实知道那个声音。是克里德。对。不管怎样，这是我第一次真正有了一些严肃的台词。
It was six and a half pages. I remember Kent and Subornac threw the script down and said, okay, here it is. This is your, this is your moment. Wow. And I, I had memorized it forwards and backwards. I had set a timer on a little recorder at night, subliminally at two and three in the morning that would go off and play the lines while I was sleeping. Creed.
有六页半。我记得肯·苏博纳克把剧本往桌上一扔，说，好了，就是这样。这是你的，这是你的高光时刻。哇。我把它正着背倒着背都背熟了。晚上我还在一个小录音机上设置了定时器，在凌晨两三点潜意识地播放，在我睡觉的时候播放台词。克里德。
I had it backwards and forth. No joke. I had it backwards. Wow. I knew this was the Rubicon. This is the place that I was going to get. My intuition said, this is it. And then, of course, we walk in the office and Greg, they came in and said, by the way,
我正着倒着都会背了。不开玩笑。我正着都会。哇。我知道这是卢比孔河。这是我要取得成功的转折点。我的直觉告诉我，就是这个。然后，当然，我们走进办公室，格雷格，他们进来对我说，顺便说一句，
we made changes, of course, to the, to the, to the lines and we've reversed them around and add some new stuff. Okay. So he goes, yeah, fine. I go, go. Cause they used to do that to us all the time. Oh, we would come in and you'd just get new pages. Yep.
我们对台词做了修改，当然，对台词做了修改，我们把它们颠倒了顺序，还加了一些新东西。好吧。所以他说，好吧，行。我说，走吧。因为他们以前经常对我们这样做。哦，我们会进来，然后你就会拿到新页数。没错。
And then shoot the scene five minutes later. Yeah. Yeah. They would hand you the pages and sometimes we've talked about this. The pages would be hot. Right off the copier. Because they just came right off the copier. And we'd drop them.
然后五分钟后就拍这场戏。是的。是的。他们会把剧本交给你，有时我们谈过这个。剧本还是热的。刚从复印机里出来。因为它们刚从复印机里出来。我们会掉下来。
So they go, ow, ow, ow, ow. Now change, now change your lines that you have learned and you've been having a tape recorder play at three in the morning to you. You remember the backdrop, they're right off of where my desk and Kate's desk was and it was the screener. So you could walk, you could sneak around the back and get to the green room from behind it. I walked that set up like that.
所以他们说，哎哟，哎哟，哎哟，哎哟。现在改，现在改你已经学会的台词，那是你一直在让录音机在凌晨三点对你播放的台词。你还记得那个背景，就在我和凯特的办公桌旁边，那是休息室的屏风。所以你可以走过去，从后面偷偷溜到后台休息室。我就是那样走那个布景的。
I walked back like that after they told me this and put my hands up and said, okay, here it is. And I said, I've come this far. I'm going to do this. And once we started that with Steve, it was like into, into battle, you know. Yeah. And there was some improvisation on that scene because I was paraphrasing my lines because I was desperate.
他们告诉我这些之后，我就是那样走回去的，把双手举起来，说，好吧，就是这样。我说，我已经走了这么远了。我要把这个完成。一旦我们和史蒂夫开始了，就像是进入战场，你知道的。是的。那场戏有一些即兴发挥，因为我在意译我的台词，因为我很绝望。
Well, you knocked it out of the park, Creed. Yeah. Yeah. Well, Creed, you started out as a musician. Yep. You started out as a very long successful career as a musician. How did you even end up on the show in the first place as our stand in slash background person?
嗯，你完成得太棒了，克里德。对。对。克里德，你一开始是个音乐家。对。你作为音乐家开启了非常漫长且成功的职业生涯。你当初是怎么阴差阳错来到这部剧里，当我们的替身兼背景演员的？
Background person. I was working on Bernie Mac and Ken Quapas came on to direct an episode and they'd been using me for all these little vignettes and where I was doing funny. If you ever watch old Bernie Mac, you'll see me all the time in the background mugging up. I really want to see that. I want to go back. I'm always in the background doing some stupid stuff and they didn't allow me because I made
背景演员。我在拍《伯尼·麦克秀》，肯·夸帕斯来导演其中一集，他们一直让我演这些小插曲，我在里面表现得很搞笑。如果你看过老版的《伯尼·麦克秀》，你会经常看到我在背景里做鬼脸。我真的很想看那个。我想回去看看。我总是在背景里做一些愚蠢的事情，他们不让我演，因为我把
Bernie laugh. I made them laugh. And so Ken was talking about this guy's funny and he heard from Joe Moore, the first AT that I was on in the grassroots. So he went, he sent to Amoeba for some albums for me to sign because he was a big grassroots fan. And we started talking and talked about music and he's very knowledgeable. Then I found out that he was doing the Office of American Workplace and I was a big fan of
伯尼逗笑了。我把他们逗笑了。所以肯一直在说这家伙真逗，他从乔·摩尔——我当时在草根乐队时认识的第一助理导演——那里听说了这件事。所以他去阿米巴唱片店买了一些我的专辑让我签名，因为他是草根乐队的超级粉丝。我们开始聊天，谈论音乐，他知识非常渊博。后来我发现他在做美国工作场所的《办公室》，我是
the Ricky Gervais show. So he gave me his number. Now, I've never, ever called anybody like that before. I called him as my intuition said, this feels right. This feels right. And Ken would not have given you his number. I feel like Ken is so discerning. Oh my God.
瑞奇·热维斯节目的超级粉丝。所以他给了我他的电话号码。现在，我从来、从来没有给这样的人打过电话。我打了，因为我的直觉告诉我，这感觉很对。这感觉很对。肯是不会把电话号码给你的。我觉得肯眼光太高了。哦，天哪。
Yeah, he didn't mean call me. Yeah. Yeah. So he did. And so he talked to Greg and then I talked to Ken later and he said, well, I talked to Greg. I told him you were a very interesting and funny guy and he said, well, what we'll do and this is his words, Greg's words, we'll put him in the background and see if we can
是的，他不是那个意思，叫我打的。是的。是的。所以他打了。然后他跟格雷格谈了，我后来又跟肯谈了，他说，嗯，我跟格雷格谈过了。我告诉他你是个非常有趣和搞笑的家伙，他说，好吧，我们要做的，这是他的原话，格雷格的原话，我们把他放在背景里，看看能不能
work him into the mix in that first time. That was working in the mix. That's all I need to hear. That's why I took liberties just kind of like pretending that I was a part of the part of the group and that paid off, you know, yes. Oh, I love that. Oh, that is awesome. That is awesome.
在第一次把融入其中。那是融入其中。我只需要听到这个。这就是为什么我有点擅作主张，假装自己是团队的一部分，而这得到了回报，你知道的，是的。哦，我太喜欢了。哦，这太棒了。这太棒了。
What's next? Should we do a summary? Jenna, do you have one? You know, I do. Yes. In this episode, Halloween, Michael is told that he must fire someone during the month of October due to cutbacks at Dunder Mifflin. But in true Michael fashion, he waits until the very last day of October, which also happens
接下来是什么？我们要不要做个总结？珍娜，你有一个吗？你知道的，我有。是的。这一集里，万圣节时，迈克尔被告知由于邓德·米夫林公司的开支削减，他必须在十月份期间解雇一个人。但秉持迈克尔一贯的风格，他拖到了十月的最后一天，而这一天
to be Halloween. He also has no idea who to fire. He has not made a decision. He spends the entire episode trying to figure out what to do while the rest of us are dressed in our costumes for the Halloween party. I love that. I love that. So much.
正好也是万圣节。而且他根本不知道该解雇谁。他还没有做出决定。他花了整整一集的时间想办法该怎么做，而我们其他人则穿着万圣节派对的服装。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。太棒了。
I love the proposition of that someone is going to get fired while wearing a ridiculous costume and they're going to have to go home fired in that outfit. Well, I have a fast fact about this episode. Fast fact number one, Greg Daniels wrote this episode and he told me that the inspiration for this episode was that he had always wanted to do a story about someone being fired. But from the point of view of the boss rather than the employee, he felt like we always see stories of people being fired and how they're wrestling with having been fired. But he was like, you never see what it does to the boss.
我喜欢这种设定：有人穿着荒谬的服装被解雇了，而且他们还得穿着那身衣服被解雇回家。好吧，我有一个关于这一集的快速事实。快速事实一，格雷格·丹尼尔斯写了这一集，他告诉我这一集的灵感来自于他一直想做一个关于有人被解雇的故事。但它是从老板的角度而不是员工的角度出发的，他觉得我们总是看到人们被解雇以及他们如何纠结于被解雇的故事。但他觉得，你永远看不到这对老板有什么影响。
That's the genius of Greg Daniels right there. Absolutely. Well, the problem that this plot presented for Greg was that he was going to have to fire someone on the show. He was going to have to pick a Dunder Mithlin employee to be part of the plot. Well, he couldn't fire any of the series regular characters because we all had contracts and he didn't want to fire any of the supporting cast, even though at this point, you guys still did not have your full time contracts, right?
这就是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的天才之处。绝对是的。嗯，这个情节给格雷格带来的问题是，他必须解雇剧中的某个人。他必须挑选一个邓德·米夫林公司的员工来作为情节的一部分。嗯，他不能解雇任何常规演员，因为我们都有合同，而且他不想解雇任何配角，尽管此时此刻，你们俩当时还没有全职合同，对吧？
We didn't become series regulars till Booz Crews, so listen, we were all on the chopping block. Were you a little worried when you saw this? Well, maybe. Well, Greg didn't have any intention of losing them. He didn't want to lose anyone in the warehouse, but he also told me he didn't want to hire someone new that you'd never seen on the show just to fire them. He felt like those stakes would feel very manufactured.
直到《船上狂欢》我们才成为常规演员，所以听着，我们都在砧板上。当你看到这个时，你有点担心吗？嗯，也许吧。嗯，格雷格并没有打算失去他们。他不想失去仓库里的任何人，但他也告诉我，他不想只是为了解雇某人而雇佣一个你在剧中从未见过的新人。他觉得那种利害关系会显得非常人为。
So he turned to our two background actors, Creed and Devon, and he was like, well, these guys are very well established on the show at this point, and this is where I'd like to know what happened because I know the end of this story, which is that Greg found out that Devon had a theater contract coming up that he was going to go on tour with a play, and so that's where Devon said, at the time, though, they told us, one of you guys are going to have to go. But we don't know yet. We're just going to do that.
所以他转向我们的两个背景演员，克里德和德文，他说，好吧，这些人在这个时候已经在剧中很稳固了，这就是我想知道发生了什么的地方，因为我知道这个故事的结局，那就是格雷格发现德文有一个即将到来的戏剧合同，他要随剧团去巡演，所以这就是德文说的，不过当时他们告诉我们，你们俩得走一个。但我们还不知道。我们只是要这样做。
We're going to shoot you both. We're going to see how it works out. Oh, my God. Wait. They're going to shoot the scene two ways? Well, they know that we're going to shoot the thing because they could have gone back and changed it. I'm sure.
我们打算拍两个版本的结局。我们要看看效果如何。哦，天哪。等等。他们要用两种方式拍这场戏？嗯，他们知道我们要拍那个，因为他们本可以回去改的。我确信。
Oh, because Michael could have said, you know what? I said it was Creed, and it's Creed. You can't change my mind. But it was going to be one of us. They said it was going to be one of us, and I remember being a little nervous. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
哦，因为迈克尔本可以大喊，你知道吗？我说过是克里德，那就是克里德。你改变不了我的决定。但肯定会是我们其中之一。他们说是我们其中之一，我记得当时有点紧张。对。对。对。
And Devon and I were friends. We'd become friends by this time. And by the way, you know, on the finale, jumping ahead a lot, I don't know if I could kind of jump ahead. Yeah, you can. When Greg brought me into the office to find out what I wanted to do for the Creed character, I said, well, one thing I like to do is sing the song, but my song, but I also think we should have Devon back on the show.
我和德文是朋友。到这个时候我们已经成为朋友了。顺便说一句，你知道的，在结局那集，跨度有点大，我不知道我能不能跨度这么大。是的，你可以。当格雷格把我叫进办公室问我想为克里德这个角色做些什么时，我说，好吧，我喜欢做的一件事是唱歌，唱我自己的歌，但我也觉得我们应该让德文回到剧组里。
Oh, Creed. That's nice. Yeah. Because we get together sometimes, you know, and have to have coffee and stuff like that. I was feeling nervous because I kind of was feeling bad that I might have to go, but also that Devon might have to go, too. So it was a mixed blessings and all that stuff. All right.
哦，克里德。太好了。是的。因为我们有时会聚在一起，你知道的，喝咖啡什么的。我当时觉得很紧张，因为我有点内疚，觉得自己可能得走，但也觉得德文可能也得走。所以这是福祸相依吧。好吧。
Fast fact number two. This is the first time we see Pam's hair down instead of her usual half up, half down hair clip. But the cat ears. That, to me, is so important. Yeah. Oh, well then, Creed, then Creed, you're going to love some of my note cards if that's important. Buckle in.
快速事实二。这是我们第一次看到潘把头发放下来，而不是她平时那种半扎半放的发夹造型。还有猫耳朵。对我来说，这太重要了。对。哦，那么，克里德，如果这很重要的话，你一定会喜欢我的一些小卡片的。系好安全带。
This is a huge deal. Kim Ferry, our hairstylist, and me, and Greg, and Paul Feig, we all had a meeting about Pam's hair and if we could let her hair down. And it was, I mean, it must have been 30 minutes. We talked about it. There was a lot of concern that she might look too pretty with her hair down. And I can't remember how we got permission. Kim was delighted.
这是一件大事。金·费里，我们的发型师，还有我、格雷格和保罗·费格，我们开会讨论了潘的头发以及是否可以把她的头发放下来。而且，持续时间至少有30分钟。我们一直在讨论。大家很担心她把头发放下来会不会显得太漂亮了。我不记得我们是怎么得到批准的。金很高兴。
I mean, Kim had been putting my hair in a hair clip now for like 12 episodes or something. She was so thrilled to be able to scrunch it. Do something different. Anything. Yeah. Anything different. And it was kind of a big deal. So.
我是说，金已经把我的头发用发夹夹了大概12集了。她能把头发抓蓬松，简直太激动了。做点不同的事。什么都行。是的。什么都行。这算是件大事。所以。
Well, they were playing down both of your beauties all the time with the way they dressed you and put you in stuff. That's right. Did everyone hear that? Did you fight? Did you fight? That's true. Creed says they played down our beauty.
好吧，他们一直通过给你们打扮和穿衣服来压低你们两人的美貌。没错。大家都听到了吗？你们吵架了吗？你们吵架了吗？这是真的。克里德说他们压低了我们的美貌。
That's true. Toward the end, did you guys lobby for, come on. Just let us show a little bit of, you know. I remember really wanting lip gloss. Yeah. Something like that. One thing to me is that that was a 30 minute meeting about your hair. Meanwhile, I go to hair and makeup and they put on full, enormous, purple, fake eyelashes
这是真的。到了后期，你们有没有游说，拜托。让我们稍微展示一下，你知道的。我记得真的很想要唇彩。是的。诸如此类。对我来说，那是关于你头发的30分钟会议。与此同时，我去发型和化妆部门，他们给我戴上了全套、巨大、紫色、假的假睫毛。
on me. If you look at me as this cat, I have big purple eyelashes. They were so huge. I had a hard time like even navigating them. Like I look, when I watch the episode, I look a little sleepy. I think it's because I couldn't open my eyes. No meeting. No meeting.
如果你们看我扮的这只猫，我有巨大的紫色假睫毛。它们太大了。我甚至很难驾驭它们。当我看这一集时，我看起来有点困。我想是因为我睁不开眼睛。没有会议。没有会议。
They just put, I was like, are you sure? They just put them on me. And then one of the writers walked up to me, I can't remember who, and was like, do you have purple? It's probably Mindy. She was like, do you have purple lashes on? She might have been jealous. Yeah.
他们只是把，我当时想，你确定吗？他们直接给我戴上了。然后其中一个编剧走过来找我，我不记得是谁了，然后问，你有紫色？大概是敏迪吧。她当时问，你戴了紫色睫毛吗？她可能嫉妒了。是的。
Yeah. She wanted them. She would want those purple lashes. No one said anything. Why is Angela Martin putting on purple fake eyelashes? Everyone was too busy meeting about my hair. Yeah. Yes.
是的。她想要。她会想要那些紫色睫毛的。没人说什么。为什么安吉拉·马丁要戴紫色假睫毛？每个人都忙着开关于我头发的会去了。对。是的。
Yes. All right. Fast fact number three. Creed, I don't know if you remember this. Angela, I think maybe you do. Last week we shot the Halloween episode, Ricky Gervais and Steven Merchant visited one day. I know this because I have a photograph with them in my cat outfit, and Jim is three hole punched Jim, but you can't really see the holes because he's got his arm around someone.
是的。好吧。快速事实三。克里德，我不知道你还记不记得这个。安吉拉，我想你可能记得。上周我们拍万圣节那一集时，瑞奇·热维斯和史蒂芬·莫 merchant有一天来探班了。我知道这一点，因为我和他们有一张合影，我穿着猫咪服装，吉姆是三孔打孔吉姆，但你其实看不到那些孔，因为他的胳膊搭在某人身上。
So it's a whole picture of our producers, and Ricky and Steven, and me and John, and I am the only person wearing a costume. I like to imagine that they came to see me in a play where I played a cat or something. Your one act play? Because we look like we're standing backstage. And you're in the cat, yeah. You're the only one in a costume. Yeah.
所以这是一张我们制片人、瑞奇、史蒂芬、我和约翰的合影，而我是唯一一个穿着戏服的人。我喜欢想象他们是来看我演的一部戏剧，我在里面扮演一只猫什么的。你的独幕剧？因为我们看起来就像站在后台一样。而你穿着猫服，是的。你是唯一一个穿戏服的人。是的。
This is how I know this because I only have two pictures of myself with Ricky and Steven, and one of them is me in a cat costume. I remember that they were there because my ears still hurt from that high castralto. Ricky Gervais, the laugh. That's such a good impression. He laughed. He laughed at everything. He was so good natured.
这就是我为什么知道这一点，因为我只有两张自己和瑞奇、史蒂芬的合影，其中一张就是我穿着猫服的照片。我记得他们在那里，因为我的耳朵现在还被那个高亢的假声震得疼。瑞奇·热维斯的笑声。模仿得太像了。他笑了。他什么都笑。他脾气太好了。
He was like some coffee. Yeah. Oh, by the way, ladies and gentlemen, he is the sweetest man, and just a joy. All right. Those are my Fast Facts. That's our summary. Maybe we should, do we need that bathroom break? Let's do a bathroom break.
他就像要点咖啡一样。是的。哦，顺便说一句，女士们先生们，他是最甜美的人，简直是个开心果。好吧。这些是我的快速事实。这是我们的总结。也许我们应该，我们需不需要上个厕所？我们去上个厕所吧。
Let's do a bathroom break. I could use one. By the way, I just want to say I just love these Fast Facts. Oh, well then, if you love the Fast Facts, get ready for the note cards, Creed. Oh my God. I can't wait. Be still, my throbbing heart. Okay.
我们去上个厕所吧。我正想去呢。顺便说一句，我只想说我太喜欢这些快速事实了。哦，好吧，如果你喜欢快速事实，克里德，那就为小卡片做好准备吧。哦，天哪。我等不及了。我的小心脏啊，别跳了。好吧。
Sounded a little weird when you said it like that. Started to be weird, and then I drifted away. Okay. Go back, go to the bathroom. All right. Let's get into some note cards. Note cards. Can we?
你刚才那么说的时候听起来有点怪。开始时觉得怪，然后我就思绪飘远了。好吧。回去吧，去上厕所。好吧。让我们进入小卡片环节。小卡片。我们可以吗？
Yeah. All right. Let's get into the episode. Let's do it. I have a note card from the cold open. Oh, what is the cold open of this episode? The cold open is you say that Jan called, and he's like, oh, and Michael has to go in because he knows he has to fire someone.
可以。好吧。我们进入这一集吧。开始吧。我有一张来自片头冷笑话的小卡片。哦，这一集的片头冷笑话是什么？片头冷笑话是你说简打来电话，他说，哦，迈克尔不得不接，因为他知道他必须解雇某人。
And so he calls Jan, and her assistant, Sherry, answers the phone. And Sherry has so much good sass. She's like, okay, well, who are you going to fire? And he goes, well, I'm not really sure. And she's like, we just need the name. Jan needs the name. Jan needs the name. Yes.
于是他给简打电话，她的助理雪莉接了电话。雪莉太会呛人了。她说，好吧，你打算解雇谁？他说，嗯，我其实不太确定。她说，我们只需要名字。简需要名字。简需要名字。是的。
And then he's like, who would you fire? And she's like, just give me the name. And then he thinks he's hung up, and he's like, I'd like to fire you. And she goes, still here. Right? And she's like, I wish I could fire Sherry. Sherry. I mean, I want to know who Sherry is.
然后他说，你会解雇谁？她说，把名字给我就行。然后他以为自己挂了电话，说了一句，我想解雇你。她回答，我还在线呢。对吧？然后他说，我真希望我能解雇雪莉。雪莉。我的意思是，我很想知道雪莉是谁。
Who is Sherry? Yes. I thought the same thing. So the first thing I did, I went to IMDB, Internet Movie Database. I did too. I looked up this episode, Uncredited. Uncredited. Who is Sherry?
雪莉是谁？是的。我也是这么想的。所以我做的第一件事，就是去了IMDB，互联网电影资料库。我也去了。我查了这一集，演员表未署名。未署名。雪莉是谁？
Who is Sherry? I reached out to Dave Rogers. He was the editor for this episode. You guys, he knows everything about the office. He didn't know. That is saying something, because he is like, he knows everything. He's in the Bible of the show. He's encyclopedic memory, cat.
雪莉是谁？我联系了戴夫·罗杰斯。他是这一集的剪辑师。伙计们，他对《办公室》无所不知。他不知道。这就说明问题了，因为他就像，他什么都知道。他是这部剧的圣经。他有百科全书般的记忆力，猫。
No one knows. Listen to what Dave did. Dave reached out to Allison Jones, our casting director, who went to her storage facility. Oh my Lord. Found the contracts for this episode, looked it up. Wow. Allison, thank you. Oh my gosh.
没人知道。听听戴夫做了什么。戴夫联系了艾莉森·琼斯，我们的选角导演，她去了她的储藏室。哦，天哪。找到了这一集的合同，查了一下。哇。艾莉森，谢谢你。哦，天哪。
Allison, you're like an episode of the Pelican Brief, an episode. This is CSI the Office. You're like CSI the Office. It is Lisa Malone, and by the way, this was shot on September 13th, 2005. Wow. Well, Lisa, you were fantastic at Sherry. You killed it. You killed it as Sherry.
艾莉森，你就像《鹈鹕暗杀令》里的一集，一集。这就是《办公室》的犯罪现场调查。你就像《办公室》的犯罪现场调查。那是莉萨·马龙，顺便说一句，这一集是2005年9月13日拍摄的。哇。好吧，莉萨，你演的雪莉太棒了。你把雪莉演活了。
Oh man. And Allison, thank you. Thank you for being our CSI the Office. I want to go back, Angela, because I have a note that precedes your note card. Is it at five seconds? Is it the shot of Devon and Creed at their desk? The establishing shot. Yes.
天哪。还有艾莉森，谢谢你。谢谢你成为我们的《办公室》犯罪现场调查员。我想回去，安吉拉，因为我有一条笔记在你的小卡片前面。是在五秒处吗？是德文和克里德坐在办公桌前的镜头吗？建立镜头。是的。
Yes. I noticed it too. The shot of this episode is Creed and Devon at their desks. I have to imagine this was not an accident, that they wanted to drive home Devon and Creed since we know that one of you- It was well-placed. Yes. Well-placed.
是的。我也注意到了。这一集的镜头是克里德和德文坐在办公桌前。我不得不想象这不是偶然的，他们想要突出德文和克里德，因为我们知道你们其中一个——这安排得很巧妙。是的。安排得很巧妙。
It's Phyllis putting on makeup, and then it goes to Devon and Creed at their desk. Well, the scene with Michael and Pam, do you guys remember how he's wearing the second head? Yes. Yes. Oh, I have a card. Pam goes in his office, and he tells her that he needs to fire someone, and then he sort of implies maybe it could be her.
那是菲利斯在化妆，然后切到德文和克里德坐在办公桌前。嗯，迈克尔和潘的那场戏，你们还记得他戴着第二个脑袋吗？是的。是的。哦，我有一张卡片。潘走进他的办公室，他告诉她他需要解雇某人，然后他话里话外暗示这人可能是她。
Oh, I have two cards from this scene. And so Pam decides to quickly start flattering him. She pivots hard. About his costume, and then she just gets out of the room as quickly as possible. I could not get through that scene. Listen, Steve is funny enough on his own, but Steve with that extra Steve on his shoulder, it was too much, and it wobbled in a sort of weird way. He was wobbling it on purpose.
哦，我从这场戏里记了两张卡片。于是潘决定赶紧开始奉承他。她话题转得很生硬。夸他的万圣节服装，然后她以最快的速度逃离了房间。我简直无法拍完那场戏。听着，史蒂夫自己就已经够搞笑了，但史蒂夫肩膀上扛着那个额外的史蒂夫，这就太过分了，而且它还以一种诡异的方式摇晃。他是故意让它摇晃的。
He loved it. He loved wobbling that thing. He loved it. Anytime you give him a little cat or a cat. That's what she said. Come on, guys. That was great. That's what she said.
他很喜欢。他太喜欢摇晃那个东西了。他爱不释手。只要你给他一个小猫或者猫咪。她就是这么说的。拜托，伙计们。太棒了。她就是这么说的。
Come on. He loves wobbling things. He loved wobbling that thing. Oh, that's what she said. Hey. We got it back. We got it back. We got it back.
拜托。他就是喜欢摇晃东西。他太喜欢摇晃那个东西了。哦，她就是这么说的。嘿。我们找回状态了。我们找回状态了。我们找回状态了。
Creed, what did I write? At three minutes, 12 seconds. Oh, my God. Pam is diabolical. Her turn to flattery when she realizes Michael would fire her. Wow. Diabolical. I'm just saying, I'm seeing a real DV.
克里德，我写了什么？在三分12秒。哦，天哪。潘太腹黑了。当她意识到迈克尔可能会解雇她时，她立刻开始拍马屁。哇。太腹黑了。我只是说，我看到了一个真正的DV。
It would be a streak in Pam. I want to just comment, if I may. Please. The brilliance of Steve Carell, the pain and the anguish in his face when he's trying to, when he's getting ready to fire someone, you can just see it. He's just dying. He's absolutely dying. He's not acting.
这可以说是潘的一个特质。如果可以的话，我想发表一下评论。请便。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的演技太绝了，当他尝试，当他准备解雇某人时，他脸上的痛苦和折磨，你一眼就能看出来。他简直快要崩溃了。他真的快崩溃了。他不是在演戏。
He's like, to me, he looked like a man just suffering, suffering from a dream and a death. It's interesting you bring that up, Creed, because we've talked a lot about how Michael wants to be popular. He wants to be friends with people. He wants to be the life of the party. But I think this episode goes beyond that, that it isn't just that he knows that it's going to be, he's going to not be well liked by the person he fires. I think it really, like, I think it touches on something he really doesn't want to hurt
对我来说，他看起来就像一个饱受折磨的人，被梦想和死亡折磨着。你提到这个很有意思，克里德，因为我们讨论过很多次迈克尔想受欢迎。他想和大家交朋友。他想成为派对的灵魂人物。但我认为这一集更深入了一层，不仅仅是因为他知道自己这样做会不受被解雇的人喜欢。我觉得真的，就像，我觉得这触及了他内心其实真的不想伤害
someone else. Yep. That's exactly right. Yeah. So it's deeper than that. Just unpopularity. I was moved by his performance in that. Yeah.
别人的软肋。没错。完全正确。是的。所以这比单纯的失宠要深得多。他的表演深深打动了我。是的。
Oh, yeah. I mean, yeah, he crushed it. I get more pictures at Halloween of Pam as a cat and Jim as three-hole punch. I think that is the most popular Halloween costume that I get sent to me. I get myself, well, Angela Martin in an Argyle sweater, like with a turtleneck and a headband holding a stuffed animal cat next to some guy in a mustard shirt with a tie and his hair parted down the middle. What about you, Creed?
哦，是的。我的意思是，是的，他演得太棒了。万圣节时我收到最多的是潘扮成猫、吉姆扮成三孔打孔纸的照片。我想这是人们发给我最多的万圣节服装。我自己收到的，嗯，安吉拉·马丁穿着阿盖尔毛衣，戴着高领毛衣和发带，手里抱着一只毛绒猫玩具，旁边站着一个穿芥末黄衬衣系着领带、头发中分的家伙。你呢，克里德？
I get the Joker. I want to walk into the Joker and then when Brian comes, damn it, Creed, and he hip-checks you. That's a later episode. Later. Yeah, that way you guys are both dressed in the same costume. But he almost knocks you over. Oh, yeah.
我收到小丑的照片。我想扮演小丑，然后当布莱恩走过来时，该死的，克里德，他用胯部撞你。那是后来的剧集了。以后再说。是的，那样的话你们两个就穿同一套服装了。但他差点把你撞倒。哦，是的。
I howl every time I see it. That's a recurring thing. Brilliant, brilliant. Angela, I want to talk to you about your costume. Please. Okay. Michael comes over to accounting. You're dressed as a cat.
每次看到我都笑得前仰后合。这是一个反复出现的梗。太绝了，太绝了。安吉拉，我想跟你聊聊你的服装。请吧。好的。迈克尔走到会计部。你打扮成了一只猫。
There's three cats. Phyllis is a cat. Phyllis. I'm a cat. You're a cat. Yes. Actually, we could do really quickly the rundown of costumes. Dwayne is Dorothy, Phyllis Pam and Angela are cats, Dwight is a Sith Lord, Kevin is
有三只猫。菲利斯是一只猫。菲利斯。我是猫。你是猫。是的。其实，我们可以快速过一遍大家的服装。德韦恩是桃乐丝，菲利斯、潘和安吉拉是猫，德怀特是西斯尊主，凯文是
the Dunder Mifflin superhero, Creed is a vampire, Oscar is a lady. Yeah. Yeah. I don't know if she's a character lady or just a lady. I think he's a lady. He's just a lady. Jim is three hole punch. Jim, Stanley, no costume, Ryan the temp, no costume, and of course, Michael has the
邓德·米夫林超级英雄，克里德是吸血鬼，奥斯卡是一位女士。是的。是的。我不知道她是某个女性角色还是只是一位女士。我觉得她就是一位女士。她只是一位女士。吉姆是三孔打孔吉姆，斯坦利，没有服装，瑞恩实习生，没有服装，当然，迈克尔有
two heads. And Devin was a tramp. And Devin was a hobo. Hobo. Angela, why does your cat only have two lines for whiskers and not three? Jenna, I don't know. Why does my cat have purple fake eyelashes? Why does your cat have weird cat ears?
两个脑袋。而德文是个流浪汉。德文是个流浪汉。流浪汉。安吉拉，为什么你的猫只有两条胡须线而不是三条？珍娜，我不知道。为什么我的猫有假紫色睫毛？为什么你的猫有奇怪的猫耳朵？
I mean, I just want to say that as the resident cat lady of the office, I think you have the worst cat costume. Why do I have a fuzzy white skirt? Why? With a giant tail that was almost impossible to sit in. It was so, and the skirt didn't quite fit me and it kept like heading south. I had to keep like grabbing it and yanking it up. It almost ruined the whole episode, that whole cat thing.
我的意思是，我只想说，作为办公室里常驻的猫奴，我觉得你的猫造型是最差的。为什么我有一条毛茸茸的白色裙子？为什么？拖着一条巨大的尾巴，坐在上面简直是不可能任务。太难了，而且那裙子不太合身，总是往下掉。我不得不一直去抓它把它往上提。那整套猫的造型差点毁了整整一集。
I think now, there was such a big meeting about your hair that my cat costume was just like, eh, just put this on her. But you ended up wearing that costume like two more times. For years. For years. And it's the worst one. It really is. I have a vague memory, a very, very vague memory of being in makeup and having them discuss
我想现在，当时关于你头发的会议开得太久了，以至于我的猫造型就像是，呃，随便给她套上就行了。但你最后又穿了那套衣服大概两次。好几年。好几年。而且它是最差的一套。真的是这样。我有一点模糊的记忆，非常非常模糊的记忆，当时在化妆间，他们讨论
how they were going to differentiate the three different cats. And it was decided that Phyllis and I would have three whiskers on each cheek and you would only have two. My cat was maimed. I feel like that happened. I don't know if we can ask Laverne. Laverne was our makeup artist. I don't know.
如何区分这三只不同的猫。最终决定菲利斯和我每边脸颊有三根胡须，而你只有两根。我的猫被残害了。我觉得当时是这样的。我不知道我们能不能问问拉弗恩。拉弗恩是我们的化妆师。我不知道。
I don't know. But I mean, right? I just think you had. You were smaller than you deserve three. They decided to give me less. I have to, while we're talking. That's a height reference. Yeah.
我不知道。但我的意思是，对吧？我只是觉得你有。你个子比较矮，所以配三根不配。他们决定给我少画一点。我必须得说，在我们讨论这个的时候。那是身高梗。是的。
While we're talking about this scene and accounting, I have to point out that we don't often, our camera guys didn't often do like a full character, slow pan, you know? And they do such a hilarious one. They start at Kevin's feet and they go all the way to his head while he's filing to get him in full, red, leotard. With his socks all miss bulging in wrong areas. Oh my gosh. That's great.
在我们讨论会计部的这个场景时，我必须指出，我们的摄像师通常不会做那种全景角色的慢摇镜头，你知道吗？他们拍了一个超级搞笑的。他们从凯文的脚拍起，一路摇到他的头上，当时他正在整理文件，穿着紧身的红色连体衣。袜子在错误的地方鼓起了一大堆。哦，天哪。太棒了。
It's great. I love Kevin. We should say we loved dressing up in these Halloween costumes because our outfits normally were pretty boilerplate. It was almost like we wore uniforms in a way. And our wardrobe people loved, loved. The wardrobe crew loved getting to dress us because they, it was just like gray turtleneck. Angela, give us a note card.
太棒了。我喜欢凯文。我们应该说，我们很喜欢穿这些万圣节服装，因为我们日常的戏服通常相当刻板。几乎就像我们穿制服一样。我们的服装团队非常、非常喜欢给我们换装，因为这就好像灰色高领毛衣一样。安吉拉，给我们来个小卡片。
All right. At five minutes, 23 seconds, Creed. This is a runner. Oh. This is a reference to a runner, but this is a really big deal. What? She has braided like pigtails. Her hair is down.
好的，在五分23秒，克里德。这是一个贯穿全剧的笑点。哦。这是一个贯穿全剧的笑点梗，但这真的是个大事件。什么？她扎着辫子般的双马尾。她的头发放下来了。
Her hair is down. Her hair is down. Oh my gosh. It's not in a bun. I remember. Mindy had a bun for like the whole first season and then about, I guess, we're starting. It was like a twist. A twist.
她的头发放下来了。她的头发放下来了。哦，天哪。没有盘成发髻。我记得。敏迪在几乎整个第一季里都盘着发髻，然后大概，我猜，我们开始的时候。就像是一个发卷。一个发卷。
A French twist, I think. I mean, she looked, her character really changes her look and then she starts having her hair down. She gets a little sassy, but this has been a big thing. We've been wondering when did they change her hair? This is the beginning. I see. I don't think this counts because it's a Halloween costume.
我想是一个法式发卷。我的意思是，她看起来，她的角色真的改变了造型，然后她开始把头发放下来。她变得有点泼辣了，但这可是一件大事。我们一直很好奇她是什么时候换的发型？这就是起点。我懂。我觉得这个不算，因为这是万圣节服装。
What? I'm sorry to say. No, no. I agree. I'm going to have to say I'm with Jenna. Thank you. It doesn't count. It doesn't count.
什么？我很抱歉这么说。不，不。我同意。我不得不说我和珍娜站在一起。谢谢。这不算。这不算。
Well, I don't know if I like you here, Creed. All of a sudden, I have someone. Oh, wow. The DeVito. Two against one. Oh, fart. Well, I got pretty excited because her hair was down. But it was a costume, though.
好吧，克里德，我不知道我还该不该喜欢你了。突然之间，我有了同盟。哦，哇。德维托。二对一。哦，屁啦。好吧，我当时挺兴奋的，因为她的头发放下来了。但这毕竟是服装嘛。
It wasn't a rep or day. It's a character thing. That's what I'm saying. It doesn't apply. Am I talking to Jenna or Creed? I don't know anymore. It doesn't apply. All right.
这不是平常的工作日。这是一个角色设定。这就是我要说的。这不算数。我是跟珍娜说话还是跟克里德说话？我分不清了。这不算数。好吧。
You know the scene where Pam and Jim set up a resume for Dwight to get a job someplace else? I have a fan question about that. R.C.J.H. asked, what were you typing on the computer when you and Jim were working on Dwight's resume? I was typing what we were saying. Of course you were, Jenna. Of course you were.
你知道潘和吉姆为德怀特伪造简历帮他在别处找工作的那个场景吗？我有一个关于那个的粉丝提问。R.C.J.H.问：你和吉姆在弄德怀特简历的时候，在电脑上到底在打些什么？我打的就是我们正在说的话。你当然会了，珍娜。你当然会了。
Because you're so method. I was very method. You're like, I am a responsible person. You would type out your lines on the computer while you were doing it? Yeah. Because Jim would say, like, I would say, what should we say here? And then he would say what we should say, and I would type it. And see, here's the thing.
因为你太注重体验派了。我非常注重体验派。你会说，我是一个负责任的人。你在做那个的时候会把台词打在电脑上？对。因为吉姆会说，就像，我会说，我们这里该说点什么？然后他会说我们该说什么，我就把它打下来。你看，事情是这样的。
I'm very proud of my typing skills. Oh, we know. We know. Yeah. Creed, do we know or do we know? We really know. You guys. Now I'm back on your side, Angela.
I'm very proud of my typing skills. Oh, we know. We know. Yeah. Creed, do we know or do we know? We really know. You guys. Now I'm back on your side, Angela.|||我为自己的打字技巧感到非常自豪。哦，我们知道。我们知道。是的。奎德，是我们知道还是我们真的知道？我们确实知道。天哪。现在我又回到你这边了，安吉拉。
Thank you, Creed. This is how it feels? Yes. This is how it feels. We know. When you walk in this thing with just your fingers, we'd be talking about stuff at a craft store, and your fingers would be going like you're typing, and you'd go, please. Oh, now that is not true.
Thank you, Creed. This is how it feels? Yes. This is how it feels. We know. When you walk in this thing with just your fingers, we'd be talking about stuff at a craft store, and your fingers would be going like you're typing, and you'd go, please. Oh, now that is not true.|||谢谢你，奎德。这就是这种感觉吗？是的。这就是这种感觉。我们知道。当你走进这个地方，仅仅动着手指，我们当时正在手工艺品店谈论事情，你的手指就会像在打字一样动起来，然后你会说，拜托。哦，那可不是真的。
That was too much. It was too much, Jenna. Tone of town. And then you would tell us about your typing speed and your level of accuracy. Well, you should know I was typing our actual lines because I could, because she could and I can, and I will. And you're fast too. That's right.
That was too much. It was too much, Jenna, tone of town. And then you would tell us about your typing speed and your level of accuracy. Well, you should know I was typing our actual lines because I could, because she could and I can, and I will. And you're fast too. That's right.|||那太过分了。太过分了，珍娜，镇上的语调。然后你就会跟我们讲你的打字速度和准确率。好吧，你们应该知道，我打的是我们真正的台词，因为我能，因为她能，我也能，我会的。而且你打得也很快。没错。
She's very fast. Michael's seen with Dwight when he calls Dwight into his office, and he tells Dwight that he has to fire someone, and Dwight starts naming all the people he should fire. But then, Michael implies maybe it should be Dwight, and then Michael's second head starts talking to Dwight. Do you remember Steve and Rain laughing during that scene? Because I do. I remember they could not get through that scene.
She's very fast. Michael's seen with Dwight when he calls Dwight into his office, and he tells Dwight that he has to fire someone, and Dwight starts naming all the people he should fire. But then, Michael implies maybe it should be Dwight, and then Michael's second head starts talking to Dwight. Do you remember Steve and Rain laughing during that scene? Because I do. I remember they could not get through that scene.|||她打得非常快。迈克尔和德怀特的那场戏里，他把德怀特叫进办公室，告诉德怀特他必须解雇一个人，德怀特开始说出所有他应该解雇的人的名字。但接着，迈克尔暗示也许应该解雇德怀特，然后迈克尔的“第二个脑袋”开始对德怀特说话。你还记得史蒂夫和雷恩在拍摄那场戏时笑场了吗？因为我记得。我记得他们根本拍不完那场戏。
I'm sitting out at reception in the background, and they were cracking themselves up in there. Rain was literally doubling over because he was kind of leaning forward, and he would just kind of collapse into himself. He was laughing so hard. There must be deleted scenes of that scene. Oh, man. I would love to see those. I would love to see that.
I'm sitting out at reception in the background, and they were cracking themselves up in there. Rain was literally doubling over because he was kind of leaning forward, and he would just kind of collapse into himself. He was laughing so hard. There must be deleted scenes of that scene. Oh, man. I would love to see those. I would love to see that.|||我坐在背景的前台外面，他们在里面快笑疯了。雷恩简直笑得前俯后仰，因为他身体微微前倾，然后整个人就缩成一团。他笑得太厉害了。那场戏肯定有删减片段。天哪。我好想看看那些。我太想看那个了。
That is a funny scene. He called in when we did Office Olympics, and he said one of the things he loved about directing episodes of our shows is that you could really find a shot that was cool, and you would have the support of Greg to just kind of go with it. And he sort of found that shot where Dwight as the Sith Lord has his hood kind of like, it looks like it's straight out of the movie. Yes. And they just love that.
That is a funny scene. He called in when we did Office Olympics, and he said one of the things he loved about directing episodes of our shows is that you could really find a shot that was cool, and you would have the support of Greg to just kind of go with it. And he sort of found that shot where Dwight as the Sith Lord has his hood kind of like, it looks like it's straight out of the movie. Yes. And they just love that.|||那真是一场有趣的戏。我们做“办公室奥运会”时他打电话进来，他说他执导我们节目集数最喜欢的事情之一，就是你能真正找到一个很酷的镜头，并且能得到格雷格的支持直接采用它。他当时就找到了那个镜头：扮演西斯尊主的德怀特戴着兜帽，看起来就像直接从电影里走出来的一样。是的。他们非常喜欢那个。
Shot from the side, right? Yes, shot from the side. And they sort of just found that and went with it, and Greg was totally supportive of it. And Paul was talking about how fun that was to have that creative freedom and find those little nuggets. And it's so cool-looking. We had a lot of shots like that.
Shot from the side, right? Yes, shot from the side. And they sort of just found that and went with it, and Greg was totally supportive of it. And Paul was talking about how fun that was to have that creative freedom and find those little nuggets. And it's so cool-looking. We had a lot of shots like that.|||从侧面拍的镜头，对吧？是的，从侧面拍的。他们就这样找到了这个镜头并直接用了，格雷格完全支持这样做。保罗当时在谈论拥有那种创作自由并找到那些精彩小细节是多么有趣。而且看起来太酷了。我们有很多这样的镜头。
They just weren't the cookie cutter or stereotype sitcom stuff, and we'd get to interesting shots at times. Yeah. Because our cameramen were so great. And something that we haven't talked about on the show yet is the idea of actor marks. So usually on a television show, so that they can get these shots, they put a little piece of tape on the ground. And if you, for example, if Jim had to walk up to Pam's desk, there would be a little
They just weren't the cookie cutter or stereotype sitcom stuff, and we'd get to interesting shots at times. Yeah. Because our cameramen were so great. And something that we haven't talked about on the show yet is the idea of actor marks. So usually on a television show, so that they can get these shots, they put a little piece of tape on the ground. And if you, for example, if Jim had to walk up to Pam's desk, there would be a little|||它们不是那种千篇一律或刻板的情景喜剧桥段，我们有时能拍出有趣的镜头。是的。因为我们的摄像师太棒了。还有一件事我们在节目中还没聊过，那就是演员标记的概念。通常在电视剧中，为了拍到这些镜头，他们会在地上贴一小块胶带。如果你，比如吉姆必须走到帕姆的桌子前，地上就会有一个小小的
mark on the ground, and he would have to stand exactly on that mark. And it's really hard to do. I mean, do you guys find it hard to do? I'm always, I feel like I'm always looking down for the tape, and then I get to my spot and I look up. It's like a hard thing to manage. Well on our show, we did not have that. No.
mark on the ground, and he would have to stand exactly on that mark. And it's really hard to do. I mean, do you guys find it hard to do? I'm always, I feel like I'm always looking down for the tape, and then I get to my spot and I look up. It's like a hard thing to manage. Well on our show, we did not have that. No.|||地面标记，他必须精确地站在那个标记上。这其实很难做到。我是说，你们觉得这很难吗？我总是，我感觉自己总是在低头找胶带，然后走到位置上再抬起头。这挺难掌控的。但在我们的节目中，我们没有这个。没有。
They would just let us wander. They'd say, just walk up in this general area and the camera will find you. Yeah. It was so loosey-goosey. So amazing. Didn't you say you were in a band called loosey-goosey? I was in a band called loosey-goosey. I was.
They would just let us wander. They'd say, just walk up in this general area and the camera will find you. Yeah. It was so loosey-goosey. So amazing. Didn't you say you were in a band called loosey-goosey? I was in a band called loosey-goosey. I was.|||他们只会让我们随便走动。他们会说，就在这个大致区域走过来，镜头会找到你的。是的。真是随性又自由。太棒了。你刚才不是说你曾在一个叫“随性松散”（loosey-goosey）的乐队里吗？我确实在一个叫“随性松散”的乐队里。是的。
I was in a band with Peter White, who used to play with Al Stewart, anybody probably still does. We had a band with Dave Camp on sax, and remember we played the rap party for this movie I did with work time with Bo Bridges at the beach house at Lloyd Bridges house, loosey-goosey played out there and they were dancing out there like Annette Funicello and the surf and stuff. Oh my gosh. Yeah.
I was in a band with Peter White, who used to play with Al Stewart, anybody probably still does. We had a band with Dave Camp on sax, and remember we played the rap party for this movie I did with work time with Bo Bridges at the beach house at Lloyd Bridges house, loosey-goosey played out there and they were dancing out there like Annette Funicello and the surf and stuff. Oh my gosh. Yeah.|||我和彼得·怀特一起组过乐队，他以前和阿尔·斯图尔特合作过，现在可能还在合作。我们的乐队里还有吹萨克斯的戴夫·坎普，还记得我们为我拍的那部电影办杀青派对吗，那是和博·布里奇斯在劳埃德·布里奇斯家的海滩屋拍的，“随性松散”乐队在那里演奏，大家在那儿跳舞，就像安妮特·福尼切洛和冲浪的人群那样。哦天哪。是的。
We just need you to just sit here and tell us about all your stories. Creed, you have literally the most interesting life. I have a fan question for you. I'm a fascinating character. You are. And humble too. This is a fan question from Todd Myers, and this feels like a good place to ask it. Who is the biggest rock star you ever partied with during your touring days?
We just need you to just sit here and tell us about all your stories. Creed, you have literally the most interesting life. I have a fan question for you. I'm a fascinating character. You are. And humble too. This is a fan question from Todd Myers, and this feels like a good place to ask it. Who is the biggest rock star you ever partied with during your touring days?|||我们只需要你坐在这里，给我们讲讲你的所有故事。奎德，你的生活简直太有趣了。我有一个粉丝的问题要问你。我是一个迷人的人物。你确实是。而且还很谦逊。这是来自托德·迈尔斯的粉丝提问，我觉得在这里问正合适。在你的巡演岁月里，你一起派对过的最大牌的摇滚巨星是谁？
Oh. Wow. It maybe doesn't have to be the biggest, it could just be what's the most interesting. I lived for a while at the Cameroons Highland Estates, and Linda Ronstadt was there, Laura Nero was there, Jackson Brown used to, there was a lot of people playing at this place and lived there and they would play their instrument, you hear the instruments going around the Cameroon Highland Estates, and Butch Trucks from the Almond Brothers was there and one night Butch came over.
Oh. Wow. It maybe doesn't have to be the biggest, it could just be what's the most interesting. I lived for a while at the Cameroons Highland Estates, and Linda Ronstadt was there, Laura Nero was there, Jackson Brown used to, there was a lot of people playing at this place and lived there and they would play their instrument, you hear the instruments going around the Cameroon Highland Estates, and Butch Trucks from the Almond Brothers was there and one night Butch came over.|||哦。哇。也许不一定是非得最大牌的，也可以是最有趣的。我曾在喀麦隆高地庄园住过一段时间，琳达·朗斯塔特在那儿，劳拉·奈罗在那儿，杰克逊·布朗也曾……有很多音乐人在这地方演出并住在那里，他们会演奏乐器，你能听到喀麦隆高地庄园到处都在奏乐，阿尔曼兄弟乐队的布奇·特拉克斯也在那儿，有一天晚上布奇过来了。
Wait, wait, wait, I'm so sorry, you all lived together? No, we lived at the Estates in little bungalows, you could rent these bungalows at the Cameroons Highland Estates. Now it's been fixed up a little bit. It's right next to the Veterans of War and War place, I think, right on Highland Boulevard, right on Highland Boulevard, right off the freeway, it's right there. And like a lot of artists lived there? A lot of artists were living there, so Butch Trucks from the Almond Brothers came over
Wait, wait, wait, I'm so sorry, you all lived together? No, we lived at the Estates in little bungalows, you could rent these bungalows at the Cameroons Highland Estates. Now it's been fixed up a little bit. It's right next to the Veterans of War and War place, I think, right on Highland Boulevard, right on Highland Boulevard, right off the freeway, it's right there. And like a lot of artists lived there? A lot of artists were living there, so Butch Trucks from the Almond Brothers came over|||等等，等等，等等，非常抱歉，你们都住在一起吗？不，我们住在庄园里的小平房里，你可以在喀麦隆高地庄园租这些平房。现在那里已经稍微修缮过了。它就在战争退伍军人活动中心旁边，我想，就在高地大道上，就在高地大道上，紧挨着高速公路，就在那儿。然后有好多艺术家住在那里？很多艺术家都住在那里，所以阿尔曼兄弟乐队的布奇·特拉克斯过来
one night and Griffin from the Bread and Jesse Ed Davis used to play with John Lennon came over one night and we jammed, we jammed for hours and hours and hours and hours, and there was a lot of heavyweight guitar players there at that night, and remember Butch wanted me to go back to Alabama and be the lead singer for this group Cowboy, but that never happened. Creed, your life is amazing. Jenna, I don't know that we would have been hip enough to hang out there. We would not. Well, I have a card right here.
one night and Griffin from the Bread and Jesse Ed Davis used to play with John Lennon came over one night and we jammed, we jammed for hours and hours and hours and hours, and there was a lot of heavyweight guitar players there at that night, and remember Butch wanted me to go back to Alabama and be the lead singer for this group Cowboy, but that never happened. Creed, your life is amazing. Jenna, I don't know that we would have been hip enough to hang out there. We would not. Well, I have a card right here.|||有一天晚上，面包乐队的格里芬和曾与约翰·列侬合作过的杰西·埃德·戴维斯有一天晚上也过来了，我们一起即兴演奏，我们即兴演奏了几个小时又几个小时，那天晚上有很多重量级的吉他手，还记得布奇想让我回阿拉巴马州去当“牛仔”乐队的主唱，但那事没成。奎德，你的人生太精彩了。珍娜，我不知道我们有没有那么时髦去那里厮混。我们肯定没有。好吧，我这正好有一张卡片。
Tell me. Seven minutes, 44 seconds, Creed. We have some PPC, right? Oh, I've got it down. Pam versus Angela. Angela Sass? Angela Sass, but also same category. Same category.
Tell me. Seven minutes, 44 seconds, Creed. We have some PPC, right? Oh, I've got it down. Pam versus Angela. Angela Sass? Angela Sass, but also same category. Same category.|||告诉我。7分44秒，奎德。我们有一些PPC（派对策划委员会）的内容，对吧？哦，我都记下来了。帕姆对战安吉拉。安吉拉的傲慢？安吉拉的傲慢，但也是同一类别。同一类别。
What? I get this. So my character says, what? You brought brownies? Like, what did you bring, and you're like, I brought brownies, but I brought cookies. Same category. Yeah. Same category.
What? I get this. So my character says, what? You brought brownies? Like, what did you bring, and you're like, I brought brownies, but I brought cookies. Same category. Yeah. Same category.|||什么？我懂了。所以我的角色说，什么？你带了布朗尼？就像，你带了什么，然后你说，我带了布朗尼，但我带了曲奇。同一类别。是的。同一类别。
You should have brought something savory. You know Angela Sass. Is that what you say in the thing? Same category? I say, same category. I remember that. Well, I mean, I feel like there's a backstory missing here. Did you assign me something other than brownies?
You should have brought something savory. You know Angela Sass. Is that what you say in the thing? Same category? I say, same category. I remember that. Well, I mean, I feel like there's a backstory missing here. Did you assign me something other than brownies?|||你本该带点咸味的东西。你知道安吉拉的傲慢。你在里面是这么说的吗？同一类别？我说，同一类别。我记得这个。嗯，我是说，我觉得这里少了一个背景故事。难道你分配给我的不是布朗尼吗？
I'm sure I did. That's your implication. Yes. You're implying that I went rogue and brought brownies instead of chips and dip. You clearly did. Don't you say, where's the chips and dip or something? Yes. I clearly at some party planning committee meeting said, all right, I will make sugar
I'm sure I did. That's your implication. Yes. You're implying that I went rogue and brought brownies instead of chips and dip. You clearly did. Don't you say, where's the chips and dip or something? Yes. I clearly at some party planning committee meeting said, all right, I will make sugar|||我确信我分配了。这就是你的暗示。是的。你在暗示我擅作主张，带了布朗尼而不是薯片和蘸酱。你明明就是。你是不是说了“薯片和蘸酱呢”之类的话？是的。我在某次派对策划委员会会议上明明说过，好吧，我要做糖
cookies. Why don't you bring the dip and chips, and then you show up with these fricking brownies. How dare you? Wait, Sam, can we see that? Those aren't chips and dip. No, I made brownies. What? I'm just trying to figure out why you're sabotaging things.
cookies. Why don't you bring the dip and chips, and then you show up with these fricking brownies. How dare you? Wait, Sam, can we see that? Those aren't chips and dip. No, I made brownies. What? I'm just trying to figure out why you're sabotaging things.|||曲奇。你为什么不带蘸酱和薯片，结果你却带着这该死的布朗尼出现了。你怎么敢？等等，萨姆，我们能看那个吗？那些可不是薯片和蘸酱。不，我做了布朗尼。什么？我只是在想你为什么要搞破坏。
I made brownies. And I made cookies. Same category. All right. After watching that clip, I will admit, I think Pam did go a little rogue. Clearly you assigned me chips and dip. Thank you. Yeah.
I made brownies. And I made cookies. Same category. All right. After watching that clip, I will admit, I think Pam did go a little rogue. Clearly you assigned me chips and dip. Thank you. Yeah.|||我做了布朗尼。而我做了曲奇。同一类别。好吧。看完那段剪辑，我承认，我觉得帕姆确实有点擅作主张了。很明显你分配给我的是薯片和蘸酱。谢谢。是的。
Thank you. Same category. Yeah. Same category. All right. I needed to hear that because I think, Jenna, if it was your house and you were having a party, you would be like, hey, come on. Yeah.
Thank you. Same category. Yeah. Same category. All right. I needed to hear that because I think, Jenna, if it was your house and you were having a party, you would be like, hey, come on. Yeah.|||谢谢。同一类别。是的。同一类别。好吧。我需要听到这个，因为我觉得，珍娜，如果是在你家举办派对，你就会说，嘿，别这样。是的。
All right. Guys, I think we should go to a break and then we'll come back and finish the episode. All right. Creed, how are you doing? I'm doing wonderful. I love having you here, Creed. I do too. And we are back with my delightful neighbor and an office favorite, Creed Bratton.
All right. Guys, I think we should go to a break and then we'll come back and finish the episode. All right. Creed, how are you doing? I'm doing wonderful. I love having you here, Creed. I do too. And we are back with my delightful neighbor and an office favorite, Creed Bratton.|||好了。各位，我想我们该休息一下，然后回来继续录完这一集。好的。奎德，你最近怎么样？我过得好极了。奎德，我很高兴你能来这里。我也很高兴。我们回来了，和我可爱的邻居、办公室里最受欢迎的人——奎德·布拉顿在一起。
Thank you. Yes. Creed, we're going to make you come back on this podcast all the time. I hope you're ready. Yeah. You know what? We could carpool. We could.
Thank you. Yes. Creed, we're going to make you come back on this podcast all the time. I hope you're ready. Yeah. You know what? We could carpool. We could.|||谢谢。是的。奎德，我们要让你以后经常来这个播客做客。希望你做好准备。是的。你知道吗？我们可以拼车。我们可以的。
I guess we might pick you up. You're like, oh my God, Angela lurking, lurking these office ladies. You guys, do you remember the scene where Jim takes a phone call from a potential employer for Dwight and he does a Michael Scott impression? It's really good. John does a very good job. It's at eight minutes, 34 seconds. Oh, you've got the time code.
I guess we might pick you up. You're like, oh my God, Angela lurking, lurking these office ladies. You guys, do you remember the scene where Jim takes a phone call from a potential employer for Dwight and he does a Michael Scott impression? It's really good. John does a very good job. It's at eight minutes, 34 seconds. Oh, you've got the time code.|||我想我们可以去接你。你大概会想，天哪，安吉拉在潜伏，在潜伏偷听这些办公室女士。大家，你们还记得那场戏吗：吉姆接到了一个为德怀特提供潜在工作机会的电话，他模仿了迈克尔·斯科特？真的非常好。约翰模仿得非常棒。在8分34秒处。哦，你连时间码都记下了。
Guys, is this one we find out that Michael's middle name is Gary? Oh, is this the first time it's said? Because he says Michael G Scott, Michael Gary Scott. Yeah. I don't know. Because later it was when we had the scene where we showed him as a little boy and he doesn't get all the love that he wanted because he wanted a family. That's later, right?
Guys, is this one we find out that Michael's middle name is Gary? Oh, is this the first time it's said? Because he says Michael G Scott, Michael Gary Scott. Yeah. I don't know. Because later it was when we had the scene where we showed him as a little boy and he doesn't get all the love that he wanted because he wanted a family. That's later, right?|||各位，这是我们发现迈克尔的中间名是加里（Gary）的那一集吗？哦，这是第一次说出来吗？因为他说的是迈克尔·G·斯科特，迈克尔·加里·斯科特。是的。我不知道。因为后来在我们展示他小时候的那场戏里，他没有得到他想要的全部母爱，因为他想要一个家庭。那是后来，对吧？
Yeah. That was Gary. We knew Gary there. That might be. That might be the first time. I don't know. I think I'm putting it out there. Our fans will know.
Yeah. That was Gary. We knew Gary there. That might be. That might be the first time. I don't know. I think I'm putting it out there. Our fans will know.|||是的。那是加里。我们在那儿知道了加里。那可能是。那可能是第一次。我不知道。我觉得我把它提出来了。我们的粉丝会知道的。
Our fans will let us know for sure. I loved the scene. I just thought that John crushed it as Michael Scott and it also had the Jim and Pam air high five. The first. The first. The first. High five.
Our fans will let us know for sure. I loved the scene. I just thought that John crushed it as Michael Scott and it also had the Jim and Pam air high five. The first. The first. The first. High five.|||我们的粉丝肯定会告诉我们的。我很喜欢那场戏。我只是觉得约翰把迈克尔·斯科特演得出神入化，里面还有吉姆和帕姆的空中击掌。第一次。第一次。第一次。击掌。
Yes. I'm getting creeds, getting misty. Misty eyed. I got. I literally, when I saw it, I think I audibly said out loud to no one. Oh. Yeah. Super cute.
Yes. I'm getting creeds, getting misty. Misty eyed. I got. I literally, when I saw it, I think I audibly said out loud to no one. Oh. Yeah. Super cute.|||是的。我有种奎德要落泪的感觉。眼眶湿润了。我当时……我真的，当我看到那一幕时，我想我自言自语地大声说出来了，没对任何人说。哦。是的。超级可爱。
Okay. So I have a question about the air high five. Say it. So I was trying to do the air high five with my daughter, Isabel. Now granted, she's 11. I'm 48. Maybe we are timings off. We couldn't get it.
Okay. So I have a question about the air high five. Say it. So I was trying to do the air high five with my daughter, Isabel. Now granted, she's 11. I'm 48. Maybe we are timings off. We couldn't get it.|||好的。所以我有一个关于空中击掌的问题。说吧。我当时正试图和我的女儿伊莎贝尔一起做空中击掌。当然啦，她11岁。我48岁。也许我们的时机没对上。我们怎么也做不对。
It's difficult. We just did it perfectly. Yeah. And you know what? We kind of did it perfectly the first time. It was meant to be. It was meant to be. That speaks to our chemistry, I believe.
It's difficult. We just did it perfectly. Yeah. And you know what? We kind of did it perfectly the first time. It was meant to be. It was meant to be. That speaks to our chemistry, I believe.|||这很难。我们刚才配合得天衣无缝。是的。而且你知道吗？我们第一次做的时候就配合得近乎完美。这就是命中注定。这就是命中注定。我相信这说明了我们之间的默契。
So shortly after this momentous air high five, very sadly, Pam tells Jim he should go for the job at Cumberland Mills, but the job is in Maryland and he is so hurt. This happens a lot with you guys. Yeah. Him going off to do a job. Recurring theme. Right. It is because he's, you know, later he's going to go off to the other branch.
So shortly after this momentous air high five, very sadly, Pam tells Jim he should go for the job at Cumberland Mills, but the job is in Maryland and he is so hurt. This happens a lot with you guys. Yeah. Him going off to do a job. Recurring theme. Right. It is because he's, you know, later he's going to go off to the other branch.|||所以在这次意义重大的空中击掌后不久，非常令人伤心的是，帕姆告诉吉姆他应该去争取坎伯兰米尔斯的工作，但那份工作在马里兰州，他深受打击。你们之间经常发生这种事。是的。他为了工作离开。这是个反复出现的桥段。没错。是的，因为他，你知道的，后来他要去另一个分部。
And then later to New York and do that stuff with the sports thing. Right. Yeah. And then you go to art camp or school. Art camp? I went to a university. Thank you very much. And then she goes to.
And then later to New York and do that stuff with the sports thing. Right. Yeah. And then you go to art camp or school. Art camp? I went to a university. Thank you very much. And then she goes to.|||然后后来又去纽约做体育方面的工作。没错。是的。然后你去艺术夏令营或者学校。艺术夏令营？我去的是大学。非常感谢。然后她去了。
Art camp. Plaster of Paris making place. Geez. But yes, they constantly are being pushed together and pulled apart, right? Yeah, they are always. Yeah. It's true. But sometimes just through a comment, we're seeing in this second season, in each episode,
Art camp? Plaster of Paris making place. Geez. But yes, they constantly are being pushed together and pulled apart, right? Yeah, they are always. Yeah. It's true. But sometimes just through a comment, we're seeing in this second season, in each episode,|||艺术夏令营？做石膏模型的地方。天哪。不过是的，他们不断地被推到一起又被拉开，对吧？是的，他们一直都这样。是的。确实如此。但有时仅仅通过一句话，我们在第二季的每一集中都能看到，
there seems to be a really sweet moment with Jim and Pam and then a moment where someone gets their feelings hurt a little bit, so many feelings, so many feelings, feelings. But then at the end, Jim admits that if it weren't for Pam, he would take the job at Cumberland Mills because the pay is twice as much. It's a better job. Yada, yada. So why is he staying? He just basically admitted why he stays at this job.
there seems to be a really sweet moment with Jim and Pam and then a moment where someone gets their feelings hurt a little bit, so many feelings, so many feelings, feelings. But then at the end, Jim admits that if it weren't for Pam, he would take the job at Cumberland Mills because the pay is twice as much. It's a better job. Yada, yada. So why is he staying? He just basically admitted why he stays at this job.|||似乎总有一个吉姆和帕姆之间非常甜蜜的时刻，接着就会有一个人的感情受到一点伤害的时刻，太多的情感，太多的情感，情感。但最后，吉姆承认，如果不是为了帕姆，他就会接受坎伯兰米尔斯的工作，因为薪水是两倍。这是一份更好的工作。巴拉巴拉。那他为什么还要留下来？他刚才基本上承认了自己留在这份工作上的原因。
Yes. Yeah. And then there he admitted that crabs are his favorite food, so he was going to go to this. Maryland. Well, it's at Maryland, but that was it. Yeah. That was the crab thing.
Yes. Yeah. And then there he admitted that crabs are his favorite food, so he was going to go to this. Maryland. Well, it's at Maryland, but that was it. Yeah. That was the crab thing.|||是的。是的。然后他在那里承认螃蟹是他的最爱，所以他打算去这个地方。马里兰。嗯，是在马里兰，但就是这样。是的。这就是关于螃蟹的事。
Yeah. Soft-shelled crab. Soft-shelled crabs. Are apparently one of his favorites. Yes, exactly. Who knew that? Well, he eats that tuna sandwich every day for lunch. We didn't know that.
Yeah. Soft-shelled crab. Soft-shelled crabs. Are apparently one of his favorites. Yes, exactly. Who knew that? Well, he eats that tuna sandwich every day for lunch. We didn't know that.|||是的。软壳蟹。软壳蟹。显然是他的最爱之一。是的，没错。谁能想到呢？好吧，他每天午饭都吃那个金枪鱼三明治。我们以前并不知道。
No. So he is a seafood fan. Yes. So he just stinks all the time. I guess so. And he could have called him crab if he wanted to. Oh, crabby. Jim eats tuna sandwiches and Pam eats sour cream and onion chips.
No. So he is a seafood fan. Yes. So he just stinks all the time. I guess so. And he could have called him crab if he wanted to. Oh, crabby. Jim eats tuna sandwiches and Pam eats sour cream and onion chips.|||不。所以他是个海鲜迷。是的。所以他身上总是有一股味儿。我猜是这样的。如果他愿意，他本可以叫他“螃蟹”。哦，暴躁鬼。吉姆吃金枪鱼三明治，帕姆吃酸奶油洋葱味薯片。
They're a match made. Wow. And I eat mung beans, apparently. Wow. What is there? The smells in this all. I know. Oh, dear.
They're a match made. Wow. And I eat mung beans, apparently. Wow. What is there? The smells in this all. I know. Oh, dear.|||他们真是天生一对。哇。而我显然吃的是绿豆。哇。那里面有什么？这所有的气味。我知道。哦，天哪。
All right. So finally, Michael asked for Jim's help, and he wants to do some role-playing where he tries to fire someone. And that is just a delicious scene. Did you enjoy that one? How did John get through it is what I want to know. When Steve is Michael, he's like, why are you doing this? I'm going to kill myself.
All right. So finally, Michael asked for Jim's help, and he wants to do some role-playing where he tries to fire someone. And that is just a delicious scene. Did you enjoy that one? How did John get through it is what I want to know. When Steve is Michael, he's like, why are you doing this? I'm going to kill myself.|||好了。最后，迈克尔寻求吉姆的帮助，他想做一些角色扮演，尝试解雇某人。那真是一场精彩绝伦的戏。你喜欢那场戏吗？我只想知道约翰是怎么拍完这场戏的。当史蒂夫扮演迈克尔时，他说，你为什么要这么做？我要自杀。
And he's like, wait, is this you as you, or who are you right now? What is happening? John has to check in. And this brings us to your big scene. Your big scene. Oh, here we are. This is it. After that scene, he calls you in and tell us, break it down for us.
And he's like, wait, is this you as you, or who are you right now? What is happening? John has to check in. And this brings us to your big scene. Your big scene. Oh, here we are. This is it. After that scene, he calls you in and tell us, break it down for us.|||然后他说，等等，这是作为你自己的你，还是你现在是谁？发生什么事了？约翰不得不确认一下。这就把我们带到了你的重头戏。你的重头戏。哦，我们到了。就是这个。在那场戏之后，他把你叫了进去，跟我们讲讲，给我们细细分解一下。
What was it like to sit in that chair, and now you're going to launch into five pages with Steve Carell? Right, right. I mean, I never had five pages with Steve Carell, or six and a half, you said, six and a half. Six and a half. Originally, they may have cut it down, but it was, it took a long. Like hours to get through that thing.
What was it like to sit in that chair, and now you're going to launch into five pages with Steve Carell? Right, right. I mean, I never had five pages with Steve Carell, or six and a half, you said, six and a half. Six and a half. Originally, they may have cut it down, but it was, it took a long. Like hours to get through that thing.|||坐在那把椅子上是什么感觉，而现在你要和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔进行长达五页纸的对手戏？对，对。我是说，我从来没有和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔有过五页纸的对手戏，或者你说的六页半，六页半。六页半。最初他们可能删减了一些，但那真的很长。花了几个小时才拍完那场戏。
And I mean, I never had more than a few lines with him one-on-one. So yeah, let's let's hear about it. Well, first of all, there was a scene where I slowly take out the teeth, you know, and I resolve myself. I gird my loins as it were, I stand up within a resolute, and I march in like Nesferatu, you know, with a purpose. Are these some of your notes that you wrote in your script? No.
And I mean, I never had more than a few lines with him one-on-one. So yeah, let's let's hear about it. Well, first of all, there was a scene where I slowly take out the teeth, you know, and I resolve myself. I gird my loins as it were, I stand up within a resolute, and I march in like Nesferatu, you know, with a purpose. Are these some of your notes that you wrote in your script? No.|||我是说，我和他一对一的台词从来没有超过几句。所以，是的，让我们听听这事吧。嗯，首先，有一场戏是我慢慢地把假牙拿出来，你知道的，我下定决心。可以说我振作精神，带着坚决的态度站起来，像诺斯费拉图（吸血鬼）一样大步走进去，你知道的，带着某种目的。这些是你写在剧本里的笔记吗？没有。
No, I'm just. Yes. This is just him storytelling, Jenna. It's the B story. I'm into the story right now. Yes. Exactly. So you march in.
No, I'm just. Yes. This is just him storytelling, Jenna. It's the B story. I'm into the story right now. Yes. Exactly. So you march in.|||没有，我只是……是的。这只是他在讲故事，珍娜。这是B故事。我现在正沉浸在故事里呢。是的。没错。所以你大步走了进去。
So I march in and then I remember I sit, I sit back like this and I put my cross, my feet, I kind of houch down and I have my arms crossed because I'm protecting myself from attack like this. And he goes, well, I'll create. I just don't like this. I said, well, you want to leave? He says, no, no, I don't know. Yes, you do.
So I march in and then I remember I sit, I sit back like this and I put my cross, my feet, I kind of houch down and I have my arms crossed because I'm protecting myself from attack like this. And he goes, well, I'll create. I just don't like this. I said, well, you want to leave? He says, no, no, I don't know. Yes, you do.|||所以我大步走进去，然后我记得我坐下，我像这样往后靠，我把双腿交叠，我有点缩着身子，双手交叉抱在胸前，因为我要像这样保护自己免受攻击。然后他说，好吧，奎德。我就是不喜欢这样。我说，怎么，你想走？他说，不，不，我不知道。不，你想走。
No, no, I don't. You're the hardest person to fire ever to leave. No, no, really. No, I'm very happy here. I said, create. I've got to fire somebody and it's got to be, well, then fire Devon, you know, he's horrible. He's a job, you know, I'm so much better at my job and I'm doing the Creed voice right
No, no, I don't. You're the hardest person to fire ever to leave. No, no, really. No, I'm very happy here. I said, create. I've got to fire somebody and it's got to be, well, then fire Devon, you know, he's horrible. He's a job, you know, I'm so much better at my job and I'm doing the Creed voice right|||不，不，我不想。你是史上最难解雇、最难离开的人。不，不，真的。不，我在这里很开心。我说，奎德。我必须要解雇一个人，而且必须是……那你就解雇德文好了，你知道的，他太糟糕了。他是个工作……你知道的，我的工作干得好多了，而且我现在的声音模仿得像模像样
now too. He goes, it goes up a bit, you know, and then I just thought, I just fought for my survival and we kept doing it over and over and over and finally and in Steve was so great. It's like you, you, you've all done scenes with people where it's forcing it. It's so hard to get through a scene. Yeah. And Steve was like, he kept tossing me like these big beach balls and I had a Nerf bat and it was just easy.
现在也是。他说，稍微上升了一点，你知道的，然后我只是觉得，我只是在为生存而战，我们一遍又一遍地拍，最后，史蒂夫真的是太棒了。就像你们一样，你们所有人都和别人拍过那种很勉强的戏。要顺利拍完一场戏太难了。是的。而史蒂夫就像，他不停地抛给我像这样的大沙滩球，而我手里拿着一根海绵棒，事情就变得很简单了。
Yeah. It was easy to hit those things, you know. God bless him. He's a very giving. He's a very giving person, you know, and when you're in scenes with him, he's so eager for you to get the laugh. He doesn't, some actors guys out there, they want to get the laugh. They want that moment and Steve is so eager to share it and really just what makes the
是的。击中那些球很容易，你知道的。上帝保佑他。他是一个非常慷慨的人。他是一个非常慷慨的人，你知道的，当你和他一起演戏时，他非常渴望你能逗观众笑。他不会，外面的有些演员，他们想要博得笑声。他们想要那个高光时刻，而史蒂夫非常渴望分享它，他真正专注的只是让
scene work is what he focuses on. You know, Dave Rogers later, he said, he's what made him laugh the most is when I stood up and I said, no, no, no, you're doing a good job. Good for you. I'm waiting. I'm waiting. I'm waiting. I'm waiting.
这场戏出彩的东西。你知道的，戴夫·罗杰斯后来，他说，最让他发笑的是当我站起来说，不，不，不，你做得很好。干得好。我在等。我在等。我在等。我在等。
My figure and all that stuff was just off the top of my head. Yeah. Yeah. When I watched, when I rewatched it, I was like, oh, that is Crete. That is classic. That is just Crete being Crete. Yeah. Yeah.
我的身材和所有那些东西都是我临时随口说的。对。对。当我看了，当我重看的时候，我就想，哦，那就是克里德。那就是经典。那就是克里德本色。对。对。
That is actually, yeah. Yeah. Because I feel like you've left me boy smells where you're like, hey, I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I was just stuttering perhaps do you know, but you were doing a bit. I was doing a bit. Yeah.
那其实是，对。对。因为我觉得你留下了“男孩的气味”这种梗，你会说，嘿，开玩笑的。开玩笑的。开玩笑的。我可能只是在结巴，你知道的，但你当时是在演一个包袱。我当时是在演包袱。对。
No. But still I look at that with fond memories. It was a great and I, and I thank Steve so much for being so gracious as an actor to work with, you know. So after that scene, Michael does fire Devon right in a much shorter scene. Oh, Devon gets so angry. He announces to the office. If anyone wants to join me at poor Richard's bar, poor Richard's bars.
不。但我依然带着美好的回忆看待那段经历。这是一次很棒的经历，我非常感谢史蒂夫作为一名演员能如此随和、好合作，你知道的。所以在那场戏之后，迈克尔确实在一个短得多的场景里解雇了德文。哦，德文气坏了。他向办公室宣布。如果有人想跟我一起去老理查酒吧，老理查酒吧……
This is the first mention of poor Richard's bar. Well, he says he gives him a chili. He gives me, she says Michael gives him a chili coupon, which is a nice nod back to the dundies. Yeah. He rips it up. He rips it up. Yeah.
这是第一次提到老理查酒吧。嗯，他说他给了他一张辣椒券。他给了我，她说迈克尔给了他一张辣椒券，这是对邓迪奖的一个很好的致敬。是的。他把它撕了。他把它撕了。是的。
But have we, because we end up mentioning poor Richard's bar over and over again and we go there eventually, but have we mentioned it yet? Oh, in the basketball episode, I think Daryl suggests that we all get drinks at poor Richard's. Okay. In that scene though, where Devon invites everyone to poor Richard's, there's three people he does not invite. Oh. Yeah.
但是我们，因为我们最后一次又一次地提到老理查酒吧，我们最终也去了那里，但是我们之前提到了吗？哦，在篮球那一集里，我想达里尔建议我们大家去老理查酒吧喝一杯。好吧。不过在那个场景里，德文邀请大家去老理查酒吧，有三个人他没有邀请。哦。是的。
You're right. Yeah. It's very personal. Who does he not invite? It's personal. Who are they? He does not invite Michael. Of course.
你说得对。是的。这很私人。他没有邀请谁？这很私人。他们是谁？他没有邀请迈克尔。当然。
He does not invite Dwight. He does not invite Angela. He does it? Invite you? Why? There's nothing. They just made this arbitrary. It's an arbitrary.
他没有邀请德怀特。他没有邀请安吉拉。他没有？邀请你？为什么？没什么。他们只是随性决定的。这是一个随性的决定。
Why not you? I'm sure I've been, you know, bitchy to him at some point. He didn't. I'm sure. Or maybe he just knew you wouldn't go. Maybe so. You might have a crush on you too. Oh, come on.
为什么没有你？我确信在某些时候，你知道的，我对他也挺刻薄的。他没有。我确信。或者也许他只是知道你不会去。也许吧。说不定他也对你有点好感呢。噢，拜托。
Oh, he might have. You never know. He leaves and he smashes a pumpkin. There we go. On Michael's car. Pumpkin. Pumpkin. Pumpkin.
哦，他可能真的有。你永远不知道。他离开了，然后砸碎了一个南瓜。这就对了。砸在迈克尔的车上。南瓜。南瓜。南瓜。
And when we go downstairs, we see Hank, the security guy at the security desk, who was played by Hugh Dane. God rest his- Yes. Yes. Who passed away a couple of years ago. He was so nice. Yeah.
当我们下楼时，我们看到汉克，保安处的那个保安，由休·丹扮演。愿上帝保佑他——是的。是的。他在几年前去世了。他太好了。是的。
Just a sweetheart. Extremely fun. And so great as Hank. His delivery was always perfect. Amazing. Is this the first time we see Hank at the security desk? I think so. It has to be.
简直是个大好人。极其有趣。演汉克演得太棒了。他的台词总是完美无缺。太棒了。这是我们第一次在保安桌看到汉克吗？我想是的。一定是。
You guys leave, you know, to go to the dojo. Yeah. But you don't see- I don't think we saw him there. You don't see him. No. Well, it's brilliant because there he is and he's sitting there and it's another example of introducing a character in an episode where they don't speak, but they will eventually.
你们离开，你知道的，去道场。是的。但你们没看到——我想我们没在那里看到他。你们没看到他。不。嗯，这很精彩，因为他就在那里，他坐在那里，这是在某一集中引入一个角色的另一个例子，他们在这一集里没有台词，但他们最终会有的。
They will come back. He did that with so many people. He did that with Craig in the warehouse and the Alliance. You just see him in the background watching Dwight Pop out of the box. Craig, of course, you were in the background forever. And then now Hugh Dane in the background is the security officer. Just so thoughtful. And this thing that I love about our show and we've talked about, Craig, is that Greg
他们会回来的。他对很多人都这样做过。他在仓库里对克雷格以及《同盟》那一集也是这样。你只能看到他在背景里看着德怀特从盒子里跳出来。克雷格，当然，你一直在背景里。然后现在休·丹在背景里扮演保安。真是太周到了。关于我们的节目，我最喜欢的一点，也是我们讨论过的，克雷格，那就是格雷格
had the audience just start in the middle. He doesn't explain things to you. You discover it as you go. It's not spoon-fed information. Yes. I love that. Well, I don't think we can end this episode without talking about Michael's list of former costumes.
让观众直接从中间开始看。他不会向你解释事情。你在观看的过程中去发现。这不是被喂到嘴里的现成信息。是的。我喜欢这样。嗯，我觉得如果没有谈论迈克尔的前扮演角色列表，我们无法结束这一集。
Oh, please list them. Okay. He's really, really bummed the camera crew wasn't there the Halloween before when he was Janet Jackson's boob. Very topical. He's really bummed you guys missed it when he was Monica Lewinsky's dress. Twice. Yeah, twice.
哦，请列举一下吧。好的。他真的很沮丧，因为去年万圣节摄像组不在，当时他扮演的是珍妮特·杰克逊的胸部。非常应景。他真的很沮丧，你们错过他扮演莫妮卡·莱温斯基的裙子的时候。两次。是的，两次。
And then he was Monica Lewinsky the year before. And then before that, he was OJ Simpson. So very topical. Great costumes that he was really sad the camera crew missed. I know you're going to want to talk about the very end with Michael and the Trick or Treaters because it's just such a touching moment. I cried every time I watched it. I did too.
然后前一年他扮演的是莫妮卡·莱温斯基。再之前，他是O·J·辛普森。非常应景。这些伟大的造型，他真的很遗憾摄像组错过了。我知道你们会想谈谈最后迈克尔和不给糖就捣蛋的孩子们的戏份，因为那真的是一个太感人的时刻。我每次看都哭了。我也哭了。
I did too. Every time. I was loving the show. And then when he got to that episode, he just killed me. I said, oh my God. This is a perfect episode. It's one of them. One of the great ones, you know.
我也哭了。每次都哭。我当时很喜欢这个节目。然后当他看到那一集时，他简直把我击中了。我说，哦，天哪。这是一集完美的剧集。它是其中之一。最棒的剧集之一，你知道的。
Yes. At the end of the episode, Michael goes home and you see him sitting alone, very lonely on the couch. And then the doorbell rings and there are Trick or Treaters at the door. And there was a big debate on set about how exactly this scene should play out about whether or not the kids should be nice to Michael or if they should be annoyed by Michael. How Michael should be with the kids. Should he be off putting?
是的。在这一集的结尾，迈克尔回家了，你看到他一个人坐在沙发上，显得非常孤独。然后门铃响了，门外有不给糖就捣蛋的孩子们。关于这场戏具体该如何演绎，片场曾有过激烈的争论，讨论孩子们是对迈克尔好，还是会对迈克尔感到恼火。迈克尔应该如何对待孩子们。他应该让人反感吗？
Should he be kind? And the writers and producers also, well, they also discussed if he should be happy or sad while handing out the candy. And they decided that they were going to start on that spy shot of Michael looking sad and lonely all alone on Halloween night. But when he gets to the door, I'm going to cry saying it. He lights up. He makes his silly jokes.
他应该友善吗？编剧和制片人们还讨论了，嗯，他们在发糖时他应该是高兴还是难过。他们决定从那个迈克尔在万圣节之夜孤零零、看起来悲伤孤独的间谍镜头开始。但当他走到门前时——我说着都要哭了。他整个人亮了起来。他讲起了傻气的笑话。
The kids laugh. The kids love him. Love him. They love him. And it ends on him making a connection. I just think it is the most kind and heartbreaking, wonderful scene. I think it's moments like this that make the office so special. We just spend an entire episode kind of laughing at Michael Scott or finding him annoying.
孩子们笑了。孩子们喜欢他。喜欢他。他们喜欢他。故事在建立起连结中结束。我只是觉得这是最善良、最令人心碎、最精彩的场景。我认为正是这样的时刻让办公室如此特别。我们刚刚花了一整集的时间来嘲笑迈克尔·斯科特，或者觉得他很烦人。
But then in the end, he just breaks your heart with his vulnerability. Take them all. They drop them. Don't worry. Take them all. Yeah. Take them all. Take them all.
但随后在最后，他用他的脆弱彻底击碎了你的心。全拿去吧。他们掉下去了。别担心。全拿去吧。是的。全拿去吧。全拿去吧。
Take them all. Take them all yours. Yeah. And that's the first time we saw him just so loving. But really? Don't you think so? At that moment, we saw his heart. We saw his heart come out there at that moment.
全拿去吧。全都是你的。是的。那是我们第一次看到他如此充满爱意。但真的吗？你不这么觉得吗？在那一刻，我们看到了他的心。我们在那一刻看到了他的真心流露。
Yeah. Well, and you tore me up. Now, it tore me up. And you have to think that Michael is somewhere being a great dad. Yeah. He's a great dad. And I wish we could see that. That's the one thing when we talk about a reunion, obviously, we don't want to tread
是的。嗯，你把我弄哭了。真的，把我弄哭了。你不得不觉得迈克尔在某处是个好爸爸。是的。他是个好爸爸。真希望我们能看到那一幕。当我们谈论重聚时，这是唯一的一点，显然我们不想践踏
on hallowed ground that is the office and we don't want to mess with anything that everyone loves so much. But boy, I would love to see where some of these people are and I would love to see Michael as a dad. Yes. Yes. Do you agree that when you watch that scene, I think more than any other scene I can recall, I see Steve.
作为办公室的神圣土地，我们不想搞砸大家如此热爱的一切。但是天哪，我很想看看这些人现在都在哪里，我很想看到迈克尔当爸爸的样子。是的。是的。你同不同意，当你观看那个场景时，我觉得比我能想到的任何其他场景都更能让我看到史蒂夫。
Yes. Mm-hmm. That is Steve handing out candy. Absolutely. Absolutely. Yes. He's a hearted gentleman that he is. Sweet, sweet man.
是的。嗯。那是史蒂夫在发糖。绝对是的。绝对是的。是的。他就是这样一个心地善良的绅士。甜美、甜美的男人。
And I think that's part of the reason to why it hits you that hard, Jenna, because we see our friend. That's true. And we see the kind person he is that gets to shine through, which often is Michael Scott does not. No, he is not. This is true. He is not.
我想这也是为什么它对你触动那么深的部分原因，珍妮，因为我们看到了我们的朋友。没错。我们看到了他善良的本性得以闪耀，而迈克尔·斯科特通常不会这样。不，他不会。这是真的。他不会的。
Well, I have one little final piece of trivia. All right. In the credits, at the end, as it rolls, over the Deedal Dee logo, which Deedal Dee is Greg's company, his daughter Haley actually drew the picture that says Deedal Dee when she was little. Oh. You hear, and it's the only time it ever happens, Dwight's voice say, quiet you. Oh.
好吧，我还有一个小小的冷知识。好的。在最后的职员表滚动时，在 Deedal Dee 的标志上方——Deedal Dee 是格雷格的公司——格雷格的女儿海莉在很小的时候实际上画了那个写着 Deedal Dee 的图片。哦。你听到德怀特的声音说“安静点，你”，这是唯一一次出现这种情况。哦。
Really? Yes. Angela. Do we know why that happened? I think they loved it. They pulled it from earlier in the episode when Dwight is the Sith Lord. Is that the only time that they've done something like that? It's the only time there's dialogue over Deedal Dee.
真的吗？是的。安吉拉。我们知道为什么会这样吗？我想他们很喜欢它。他们截取了本集前半部分德怀特扮演西斯大君时的音频。那是他们唯一一次做这种事吗？那是唯一一次在 Deedal Dee 上面有对话。
Wow. Oh, I'm kind of moved by that. That's kind of cool, right? Yeah. Quiet you. Quiet you. We did it, guys. We did it.
哇。哦，我有点被触动了。这挺酷的，对吧？是的。安静点，你。安静点，你。我们做到了，伙计们。我们做到了。
We did it. That was the Halloween episode creed. Thank you. Thank you so much for coming. But before you go, will you tell us what are you up to now? What are you doing? You have an album and you're touring. I'm touring.
我们做到了。那是万圣节那一集，克里德。谢谢你。非常感谢你能来。但在你离开之前，你能告诉我们你现在在忙什么吗？你在做什么？你有一张专辑，而且你在巡演。我在巡演。
I was in Europe, UK and in Scandinavia for a month touring and doing shows. I'm bragging now, seven sold out shows in the UK went great. I'm off to Australia, New Zealand in February. Then you did the whole East Coast too because I was texting with you and you're like, yeah. Then I did the East Coast. I had a great tour there too and the fans and I want to thank all the office fans for coming out and supporting my character and my music and it truly means a lot. I'm having my second childhood now doing this.
我在欧洲、英国和斯堪的纳维亚巡演并做了一个月的演出。我现在在吹牛了，在英国有七场门票售罄的演出，进展非常顺利。我二月份要去澳大利亚和新西兰。然后你把整个东海岸也都跑遍了，因为我和你发短信时你说，是的。然后我跑了东海岸。我在那里也有一场很棒的巡演，粉丝们——我想感谢所有出来支持我的角色和我的音乐的办公室粉丝，这真的意义重大。我现在做这个就像是在过我的第二个童年。
By the way, I have a surprise for you ladies. What is it? I've brought, which I think may be the single, if there's going to be a single from my, I'm going to play you a little snippet if you'd like, of the album. Can we do this in there? Can I play it right now for you? You guys, before he plays the song, I just want to encourage you, if creed is coming to a town near you, go see his show.
顺便说一句，我给女士们准备了一个惊喜。是什么？我带来了，这可能是主打歌，如果我的专辑里要有一首主打歌的话，如果你愿意的话，我要给你播放专辑的一小段片段。我们可以在里面放吗？我现在就能放给你们听吗？各位，在他放歌之前，我只想鼓励大家，如果克里德要到你附近的城镇，去看他的演出。
It is fantastic and apparently he also makes fun of me during it. Quite a bit, Angel, yes. We are trying to figure out one of your locations where I can come on stage and give it to you right back. Where can people find the schedule? creedbratton.com. We love your creed. All right.
这太棒了，而且显然他在演出期间还会取笑我。相当多，安吉拉，是的。我们正在设法找出你的一个演出地点，我可以上台当场回敬你。人们在哪里可以找到演出日程？creedbratton.com。我们爱你，克里德。好的。
Let's hear it. Here we go. And the ride. You taught me how, you taught me then, how I could one day be your friend, it's not so hard, just don't lie, don't control, then by and by, we'll be side by side, we'll be side by side, for the rest of the ride. All right. That's that song.
让我们听听吧。我们开始吧。还有那段旅程。你教过我，你当时教过我，我有一天如何能成为你的朋友，这其实没那么难，只要别说谎，别控制，然后慢慢地，我们会并肩作战，我们会并肩作战，度过余下的旅程。好的。就是那首歌。
There it is, gang. What do you think? Well, Angel is sobbing. I'm, I just started crying. The song is so beautiful, creed, but also, and I totally am emotional, but, oh my God, it might be too emotional. Oh, well, you know what, it just, do you ever have just like a wave hit you where you're like, you know, you're in a special moment?
就是这样，伙计们。你们觉得怎么样？嗯，安吉拉在啜泣。我，我刚开始哭。这首歌太美了，克里德，而且，我完全情绪失控了，但是，哦，天哪，可能情绪有点太饱满了。哦，好吧，你知道吗，它只是——你有没有过那种情绪突然像海啸一样袭来，让你觉得，你知道的，你正处于一个特别的时刻？
Yeah. Yes. And it just hit me. Well, I want to take with the two of you today. Yeah. I feel like we're in a special moment. It just felt really special and like something I'll always remember and I'm facing my best friend who is now my boss, lady, business partner and I'm so proud of us and, and this
是的。是的。然后它就击中了。嗯，我想今天和你们两个在一起。是的。我觉得我们正处于一个特别的时刻。感觉真的很特别，就像我会永远铭记的事情，我正面对着我最好的朋友，她现在是我的老板、女士、商业合伙人，我为我们感到骄傲，也为我们
journey we've taken together and then I just love you, creed, you're like, you're like, you know, family, family and well, I, I, I, ladies and gentlemen, when I, the last album I did, I had a song called more than you know, and I, one of the first people I ever played for it was for you and Josh, you know, at your house and I came over and acoustically played it and you know, I, and she got, and she started crying. I started crying. I knew I had a winner then. Well, creed, some of my favorite memories on the set were at lunchtime when you would
一起走过的这段旅程感到骄傲，然后我就是爱你，克里德，你就像，你就像，你知道的，家人，家人，而且——我，我，我，女士们先生们，当我做上一张专辑时，我有一首歌叫《超出你的想象》，我是第一个播放给……其中一个人听的就是你和乔什，你知道的，在你们家，我过去自弹自唱了这首歌，你知道的，然后她开始哭了。我开始哭了。那时我就知道我创作了一首佳作。嗯，克里德，我在片场最美好的一些回忆是在午餐时间，你会
play guitar and Ed would play banjo, Ed's trailer was next to mine, you'd go in his trailer and the two of you would play through my lunch and you guys would call, you'd come over and take your hat in and listen. We'd come over and hang out for years. My alarm clock is banjo music because it would make me think of you guys and sometimes, especially when I was pregnant, if we had a little break, I might take a cat nap and I'd wake up to banjo music and it was like so pleasing that I made my alarm clock banjo because I thought, oh, maybe I won't wake up grumpy Ed and I had so much fun.
弹吉他，埃德会弹班卓琴，埃德的房车挨着我，你会去他的房车里，你们两个会一直弹到我的午餐结束，你们会过来，拿着帽子进去听。我们会过去一起闲逛多年。我的闹钟就是班卓琴音乐，因为它会让我想起你们，有时，尤其是当我怀孕的时候，如果我们有一小会儿休息，我可能会打个盹，然后伴着班卓琴音乐醒来，那是如此悦耳，以至于我把闹钟设成了班卓琴，因为我想，哦，也许我醒来时就不会那么暴躁了。埃德和我玩得很开心。
He's a great banjo player. I haven't played with him in a long time because we work in all the time, but I would love to. Oh yeah. You guys were great together. He's the best. You know. Well, thank you again.
他是个出色的班卓琴手。我已经很久没跟他一起玩了，因为我们一直在工作，但我很乐意。哦，是的。你们两个在一起太棒了。他是最棒的。你知道的。好吧，再次谢谢你。
Thank you so much for having me, my dear friends. Creed, can we end with a final fan question? Yes, of course. This is from Tim Blair. Tim asked, do you have a favorite creed line from the whole show? Which one's Pam? Which question, Pam? Gosh, I don't know.
非常感谢你们邀请我，我亲爱的朋友们。克里德，我们能以一个最后的粉丝提问来结束吗？好的，当然。这是来自蒂姆·布莱尔的提问。蒂姆问，在整部剧中你最喜欢克里德的哪句台词？哪一个是帕姆？哪个问题，帕姆？天哪，我不知道。
It probably would be someone making soup or which one's Pam or, but I think, actually, I would have to be. In the 60s, I made love to many, many women, often outdoors in the rain and the mud. It's possible a man slipped in. There'd be no way of knowing. Yes. Yes, applause from the booth, and that is how you end an episode. Thank you for having me.
大概会是某人在做汤，或者哪一个是帕姆，或者，但我认为，实际上，我不得不说是这个。在60年代，我和许多许多女性做过爱，通常是在户外的雨中和泥地里。很有可能有个男人滑进来了。根本无从得知。是的。是的，来自控制室的掌声，这就是结束一集的方式。谢谢你们邀请我。
Thank you, Creed. Oh, everyone, please join us next week when we will be talking about the fight. The fight. Yeah. I'll miss you, Creed. You have to come back. Oh, I'd love to come back. Okay.
谢谢你，克里德。哦，大家请加入我们下周的节目，我们将讨论“打架”那一集。“打架”。是的。我会想念你的，克里德。你必须回来。哦，我很乐意回来。好的。
Okay. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Peefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episode's candy bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍妮·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·皮费尔。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的节目以及我们的彩蛋节目“糖果袋”，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用 Stitcher Premium 一个月，请使用优惠码 Office。本集目前还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。